Brian Nguyen: All right, quick question for everyone.
Brian Nguyen: A quick. Do you guys have questions as always just learn on Monday.
Brian Nguyen: Before we get started.
Brian Nguyen: So Chris, come back. Okay. Looks like you guys all got it experts. Okay. Alright, so
Brian Nguyen: This is important, right before you get started. Okay. I hope you guys have organized your folders. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Not yet okay it's okay right there. He says, okay, so
Brian Nguyen: For Windows users here. Please keep in mind that we want. We're going to want to save all your files in this for special now.
Brian Nguyen: Let's see here. I hope you guys know what I'm talking about the retreat and Victoria, you have Windows right
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so just keeping my from now on. Please save all your files in that directory. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Not, you know, your home directory for town in case you guys have Mac. So you're fine, don't worry about that. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: started pulling stuff.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: We're gonna get started on this.
Brian Nguyen: Will be talking about how to use purple is the program that professors Jorge, and many other people around the world has been developing
Brian Nguyen: And this program essentially helps us to use rows of calculations. And one of the things that we're deeply interested in is competing energies total energy on your molecule. All right.
Brian Nguyen: Let's get started. Let's ask everyone to like the VPN you guys to keep the and for me.
Brian Nguyen: The minute I get shut up.
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
Brian Nguyen: So,
Theresa Carlos: I think I have to log into my account. So be nice.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: You guys have VPN. Good. All right.
Brian Nguyen: Hey, we're going to do. Let's get started. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, go.
Brian Nguyen: Started okay I'm gonna share my screen.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so the first thing we want to do.
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
Brian Nguyen: So, first thing we want to do.
Brian Nguyen: Is we want to open up avocado. Okay everyone, open up your average Manager Program.
Brian Nguyen: Terminal
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so before we start playing with avocado.
Brian Nguyen: Please as make a directory or in any any any folder you want. So either you like in this desktop.
Brian Nguyen: Documents. Okay, let's discuss it says go to documents.
Brian Nguyen: Or wherever you want to save your folder. Okay, so we're going to make a folder called make directory parish high school outreach. All right.
Brian Nguyen: You can make that anywhere you save it anywhere.
Brian Nguyen: Feel free to stop me if you have questions about some bands which is kind of pretty much move pretty quickly. Alright, alright, so here is fish.
Brian Nguyen: And it will make
Brian Nguyen: A folder called geo
Brian Nguyen: Water
Brian Nguyen: Alright so what we're gonna do is
Brian Nguyen: Create a water molecule and they were no performance geometry optimization. What I mean by that is keeping the honey. The ground state energy of your molecule, but I'll explain that as we go. So first we're going to start to go into molecule first. Okay, so let's just make it very simple
Brian Nguyen: We just need to get smaller COSA oxygen and pop. There's water molecule, very easy and simple its most simplest case, you know, we can work with. All right.
Brian Nguyen: And then
Brian Nguyen: You want to minimize this molecule first.
Brian Nguyen: Start
Brian Nguyen: Right, and then you see some numbers.
Brian Nguyen: Are there, stop.
Brian Nguyen: All right, and then you want to save this. Alright. Save As.
Brian Nguyen: And are you want to go to the folder that gets created.
Brian Nguyen: I created it was the first underscore agents okie
Brian Nguyen: She'll off right in a file type I want is to XYZ XYZ
Brian Nguyen: Okay, just to know what what is x, y, z is you can think guess it's the Cartesian coordinates and that gives you the position of all your atoms oxygen, water, oxygen, hydrogen atom that
Brian Nguyen: They will save it just call it water got XYZ right to some whatever name that is most useful for you. All right. It just makes sense to me anything.
Brian Nguyen: Usually
Brian Nguyen: Right and save
Brian Nguyen: All right. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So what we have here is a guess. Okay. Initial guest and we're going to take that initial test and ever run a quantum calculation on it to get a little bit more accurate results. Okay. Alright. So before I continue on.
Brian Nguyen: So,
Brian Nguyen: For you. I have one question for you guys.
Brian Nguyen: Is that since we just made a water molecule here, right.
Brian Nguyen: How do we compete. How do we get the energy just from from this water molecule.
Brian Nguyen: tikka tikka tikka tikka Victoria stuff by last yesterday. Now, sorry I gave her the answer already. So I want to keep you guys a chance to answer this. So,
Brian Nguyen: On the Christian Teresa.
Brian Nguyen: What do you guys think
Brian Nguyen: How do you get the energy. Where do you think the energy comes from
Brian Nguyen: Um,
Brian Nguyen: You take me to, you know,
Brian Nguyen: Just simply take this molecule, take the x, y, z coordinate and put into a machine, you know it output to the energy right so
Brian Nguyen: We're, we're more our group, a little bit more, you know, like they're a little bit know a little bit more than just, you know, getting a number, we understand how to get the numbers right so maybe next question is
Brian Nguyen: We see that there are bond right prevented bond, a bond has energy right
Brian Nguyen: Right.
Brian Nguyen: So that chemistry, you'll know that you can probably compete know
Brian Nguyen: Now relative energies, they can bond.
Brian Nguyen: On a beach right right reactions and all that. Right. Okay. What
Brian Nguyen: Other questions, then where are these bond energies coming comes in.
Brian Nguyen: Right, so it goes back to your question. Okay, so then we're adding tomato really good
thanh: Protons, neutrons and electrons.
Brian Nguyen: Yeah. Good. Great. That's perfect. Yes, that's the answer I'm looking at. So we got to look at a very small sub atomic level like protons, neutrons and electrons. Alright.
Brian Nguyen: Until we're interested in those type of interactions between atoms. Okay, and we're going to be using their Cartesian coordinates of these arrows Adams to complete those energies and those interactions. Alright. So the thing about about this year is that we're only interested in the electrons.
Brian Nguyen: Right. And what is that you think is this is like a this is a textbook answer.
Brian Nguyen: In the past, I've read many times
Brian Nguyen: May be able to guide to there is what determines the chemical properties of a molecule.
You see,
Brian Nguyen: Power Shell
Brian Nguyen: Yeah, Adam.
thanh: Means electrons.
Brian Nguyen: Yesterday electron. So the valence electrons is the one that really determines the chemical properties.
Brian Nguyen: Of these
Brian Nguyen: These molecules. And we're actually continuing those interactions.
Brian Nguyen: Okay. And so let's listen for anything that
Brian Nguyen: You get out of this.
Brian Nguyen: Question.
Brian Nguyen: Yes, so
Theresa Carlos: I have a question. So I was like, I kind of missed the
Theresa Carlos: Beginning. So I
Get
Theresa Carlos: Open
Brian Nguyen: Yes, yes. Open avocado and then
Brian Nguyen: Create a water molecule.
Alright.
Brian Nguyen: And so
Brian Nguyen: Wait, before
We open
Brian Nguyen: Up of God so
Go to your terminal.
Brian Nguyen: And remember where I said,
Brian Nguyen: To stave off.
Brian Nguyen: To like save all your files.
Brian Nguyen: Or windows, you had to go into CD for splash out
Brian Nguyen: Just like that.
Brian Nguyen: I think
Brian Nguyen: When I have asked Jeffrey, help me out here. Can you
Brian Nguyen: messaged her
Brian Nguyen: via chat.
Jeffrey Tsai: Message to the
Brian Nguyen: Folder. Yeah. Yep.
Jeffrey Tsai: So it's mounts.
Jeffrey Tsai: And see
Jeffrey Tsai: For the drive and
Aakrsh: Should be the username right
Aakrsh: Yeah yeah
Brian Nguyen: Yeah message that to
Brian Nguyen: Chat to her.
Brian Nguyen: I'd like to come on
Aakrsh: Okay, thank you.
Aakrsh: Open up my Ubuntu subsystem of
Jeffrey Tsai: My other laptop to them.
All right.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so
Brian Nguyen: It's, it's, once you make molecule.
When think we were discussing
Brian Nguyen: Like once we have this molecule.
Brian Nguyen: We're going to save the file.
Brian Nguyen: I say that
All right.
Brian Nguyen: And it makes sure you're in the
Brian Nguyen: Right order to
Create
Brian Nguyen: So make sure you're in the form that you want to
Aakrsh: Put the in
Brian Nguyen: All right. Okay, we're gonna leave
Brian Nguyen: Me. We're gonna need to export the
Brian Nguyen: File later on. Okay, we want to say this XYZ XYZ is the format good senior Cartesian
Aakrsh: Coordinates.
Aakrsh: Of the items.
Brian Nguyen: Xyz physician. Alright.
Aakrsh: Just say, or
Brian Nguyen: Water dot x, y, z.
Brian Nguyen: Or is that somewhere will accidentally
Brian Nguyen: Terminal. Alright, alright. So before we
Aakrsh: Will go on to the next step.
Aakrsh: Share
Aakrsh: The concept of
Energy
You know,
I believe
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so
Brian Nguyen: Quick survey. Here I believe there's a mix.
Brian Nguyen: So has everyone taking
AP Chemistry. Yes.
Aakrsh: Yes.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, Chris, you're
Taking it
Brian Nguyen: On mutation is Theresa you're taking AP chemistry.
Brian Nguyen: Okay and Victoria. Alright, so
Aakrsh: That's not
Aakrsh: That's okay, well,
Brian Nguyen: I'll try to give you guys two spaces.
Brian Nguyen: So far,
Brian Nguyen: So when we didn't know
It.
Aakrsh: We have the
Aakrsh: Earth and talk about quantum chemistry.
Brian Nguyen: And when we talk about quantum mechanics, Steve, we always go back to talking about
Brian Nguyen: The group.
Injury.
Brian Nguyen: Right.
Brian Nguyen: We're all
Brian Nguyen: Trying to solve.
Jeffrey Tsai: That I quit. I
Brian Nguyen: hear someone saying something.
Brian Nguyen: Right there, we're trying to solve.
Brian Nguyen: The equation.
Brian Nguyen: And it's good replacement is
Brian Nguyen: He I
Mean
Aakrsh: He died.
Brian Nguyen: Right.
Brian Nguyen: There's a little hat.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so
Brian Nguyen: Here is the total energy. So I'm giving you here is a very basic really introduction to energies. Right. How do you get to see it. So he says here is
Brian Nguyen: If we call h recall is an operator.
Brian Nguyen: And operators and operator is essential to whatever mathematical
Aakrsh: Function.
You have
Brian Nguyen: That operates.
Brian Nguyen: On to your boy function.
Brian Nguyen: Right, so a function can be you know
Brian Nguyen: They're away from cheek. Think of it as
Brian Nguyen: Something that describes your system. Okay. And we'll call that side. Okay, so this symbol is caused by
Brian Nguyen: The way function.
Brian Nguyen: describing your system.
Brian Nguyen: Okay. Sometimes we call it, we kind of joke around
Brian Nguyen: And say that
Brian Nguyen: You know, we can take over the
Brian Nguyen: Waste function as the equation of life.
Brian Nguyen: And if someone can find that equation in life, and they can
Brian Nguyen: Make a bunch of money, you know, can I say so that's why we all we have to check out this job, essentially, right, and he is the
Brian Nguyen: Total energy. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: And he is just a number.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, what it does upgrade does operates on
Brian Nguyen: Its way function. It's out an energy and also the way function is so
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: drop their questions guys
Aakrsh: All right, so
Brian Nguyen: All right, so then
Brian Nguyen: Me move
Brian Nguyen: This
Brian Nguyen: I bet. All right. This is the total energy
Brian Nguyen: He is an operator and this is also known as the Hamiltonian. And so we're, what we're going to write the Hamiltonian
Right, the Hamiltonian
Brian Nguyen: They just said she ate.
Aakrsh: The Hamiltonian will give you the total energy. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: When we think of total energy
Brian Nguyen: Right essentially says
Brian Nguyen: Total energy is
Brian Nguyen: The sum of your kinetic energy and your potential energy part. Correct.
Brian Nguyen: And that's in physics somewhere.
Brian Nguyen: One example is, you can think
Brian Nguyen: Of is
Brian Nguyen: Kind of the
The hill.
Brian Nguyen: Right.
Brian Nguyen: At the
Brian Nguyen: Bottom of this hill.
Brian Nguyen: Is purely kinetic energy.
Brian Nguyen: Right.
Aakrsh: At the top of the hill.
It's purely
Aakrsh: Potential energy right
Brian Nguyen: Right. And in between is some there is
Brian Nguyen: Some between Canadian central
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
Aakrsh: So what is right.
Brian Nguyen: In here, the Hamiltonian two ways typically written
Brian Nguyen: That t
T
Aakrsh: Plus
The
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
Aakrsh: So, T is your energy.
Aakrsh: Operator and
Brian Nguyen: He is the
Brian Nguyen: Potential energy operator.
Aakrsh: Right.
Brian Nguyen: Important to know
Brian Nguyen: Before we get started, like this is how we compete the energy generally alright
Brian Nguyen: So,
Brian Nguyen: The question then becomes, is what
Brian Nguyen: Is the form of form as a
Brian Nguyen: Kind of energy and passion energy
Brian Nguyen: Well, let's start with the kinetic energy.
Brian Nguyen: Internet much easier to think about
Brian Nguyen: So,
Brian Nguyen: Oh wait, what do you guys think this negative energy
Brian Nguyen: Author is like
Aakrsh: The kinetic
Brian Nguyen: Energy operator is actually very similar
Brian Nguyen: very analogous
Brian Nguyen: To the kinetic energy that you're familiar with.
Aakrsh: The in
Physics.
Brian Nguyen: Like one half.
Brian Nguyen: And the square
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
Brian Nguyen: This is a kinetic energy to you. You're very similar
Brian Nguyen: Wishes from your physics class, but in this case.
Brian Nguyen: Regarding replaces
Brian Nguyen: The square
With a
Aakrsh: Second derivative. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so that's just kind of started, you guys.
Aakrsh: Know,
Brian Nguyen: All right, it's very similar.
Aakrsh: To what you see. And you can just
Brian Nguyen: Visit because okay
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so
Brian Nguyen: We'll go ahead and dive into too much to the math details.
Aakrsh: But just kind of
Brian Nguyen: Be familiar with it. All right. And for v.
Brian Nguyen: Is that the potential and this part.
Brian Nguyen: This piece is where we actually describe the interaction.
Brian Nguyen: On a subatomic level.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Aakrsh: Remember back when we were talking about protons and electrons, right, we're interested in those
Brian Nguyen: Types of interactions. And so we have the
Brian Nguyen: Will some this right this this way, and he
Brian Nguyen: All right, to
Aakrsh: The neutron
Aakrsh: He's electron
Brian Nguyen: Is the interaction between the electrons, neutrons,
Plus
Brian Nguyen: Yeah, think about our water molecule.
Brian Nguyen: What other interaction are there.
Brian Nguyen: Right.
Brian Nguyen: And so the interaction or new challenges and I neutron
Brian Nguyen: Right and plus
Brian Nguyen: The interaction.
Brian Nguyen: Between
The electrons.
Brian Nguyen: All right. Okay. Have questions there.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so
Brian Nguyen: What we know
Aakrsh: Is that
Brian Nguyen: We can approximate these guys.
Brian Nguyen: Because of an approximation.
Brian Nguyen: In approximate
Brian Nguyen: Any
Aakrsh: With the born
Brian Nguyen: Oppenheimer approximation.
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
This
Aakrsh: Born
Brian Nguyen: Oppenheimer approximation makes an approximation where it says that if you look at the electron and you look at the there's a proton, neutron
Aakrsh: Right.
Brian Nguyen: The match between those two particles.
Aakrsh: Is almost significantly very different. Right.
Brian Nguyen: The protons much much much much heavier, the
Brian Nguyen: Electrons right
Brian Nguyen: We can approximate by saying that they let the neutrons, much, much slower.
Brian Nguyen: And look at it, just a simple, you know,
Aakrsh: It's a simple point charge or something.
Brian Nguyen: Like that.
Brian Nguyen: Okay. And so for
Brian Nguyen: The thing that we're ultimately interested in
Brian Nguyen: Is this one.
Brian Nguyen: And this is where it gets very, very difficult to compete is the electronic electronic interaction. Okay. There's a reason why
Brian Nguyen: I won't dig into some actually
Brian Nguyen: Chima but you stopped by tomorrow, I might
Brian Nguyen: Explain. I can explain a little bit more
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Explain. Where does this come from, alright.
Aakrsh: So,
Brian Nguyen: Laws and methods that we use.
Brian Nguyen: Right in our program.
Brian Nguyen: Will be approximating this component. And depending on our approximation.
Aakrsh: You know, some
Brian Nguyen: Better you can approximate this
Aakrsh: portion of your potential
Brian Nguyen: On the day of your description of your
Overall,
Aakrsh: Overall system right
Aakrsh: That makes sense. Guess.
Brian Nguyen: This give me a nod.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so this is really bare
Aakrsh: Bones.
Brian Nguyen: All right. Okay. So,
Brian Nguyen: I'm going to save this material.
Brian Nguyen: Here.
Brian Nguyen: I'm gonna move on. Anyone have questions.
Brian Nguyen: Right, good. I'm clear, just
Brian Nguyen: Clear my drawings. All right.
Brian Nguyen: So we
Brian Nguyen: We are interested in
Brian Nguyen: The total energy
Brian Nguyen: No grounds me energy
Brian Nguyen: Right. So when you say grants the energy. We're looking for actually the lowest
Brian Nguyen: Energy state.
Brian Nguyen: For the molecules. Alright, see that, you know, makes sense rate for you're on the ground right in the very lowest point right so we always interested in that because
Brian Nguyen: molecules tend to be, you know, they like to be generally being the lowest state. I'm really
Brian Nguyen: Interested in
Aakrsh: Finding that state.
Brian Nguyen: So one way we can think about this.
Brian Nguyen: Think of this on an empty.
Aakrsh: Is why
Brian Nguyen: Does this affect okay let's draw a function that's very
Brian Nguyen: Easy to think about. Right.
Brian Nguyen: The assumption. A drawl is
Aware.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: And we then imagine
Brian Nguyen: At each of these points each of these points is some configuration of your molecule. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So at the lowest point
Brian Nguyen: Is right here.
Brian Nguyen: Is your lowest point
Brian Nguyen: Call that the lowest point
Brian Nguyen: Will
Brian Nguyen: Will actually will
I
Brian Nguyen: Were labeled the
Y Ashley's
Brian Nguyen: Labeled the Y axes as energy. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: We can imagine this as
Brian Nguyen: X is the distance
Brian Nguyen: So it's a simple molecule.
Brian Nguyen: So simple molecules can common
Brian Nguyen: Common mine is the hydrogen atom.
Aakrsh: Right.
The hydrogen
Brian Nguyen: Alright, and what we were going to adjust
Brian Nguyen: His
Brian Nguyen: Distance.
Brian Nguyen: In Tinder hydrogen atom x
Brian Nguyen: Now I should probably shifted a little bit
Brian Nguyen: To make it a little bit more
Brian Nguyen: more reasonable.
Aakrsh: Okay.
Aakrsh: Alright.
Aakrsh: If you're shifting it should be.
Jeffrey Tsai: X minus c squared x squared plus c.
Yeah.
Brian Nguyen: My
Brian Nguyen: Yeah.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, anyways, I think I have a CZ myself. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: To get it. Okay. So, all right. I just want a simple example.
Brian Nguyen: Show you. Hey,
Brian Nguyen: So we're interested in the lowest point of dysfunction. Right. And we're interested in finding that crown state.
Brian Nguyen: Energy. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: That's why we've been trying to
All right.
Brian Nguyen: One last thing is
That
Brian Nguyen: We once we get that
Brian Nguyen: Ground to the energy
Brian Nguyen: From our calculation. How do we verify that is
Brian Nguyen: If you go back to calculus.
Brian Nguyen: What's the
Brian Nguyen: What's the way I think you guys have taken calculus grip.
Aakrsh: On appreciate
Brian Nguyen: Fish, we take
It.
Aakrsh: Yeah.
Brian Nguyen: I'm
Brian Nguyen: Okay then, Chris. I'll ask you this question.
Brian Nguyen: How do you find
Brian Nguyen: So,
Brian Nguyen: How do you find the minimal
Brian Nguyen: A problem.
Aakrsh: So you can take the derivative of is to find the slope of the
Aakrsh: Very finding a minimal. Yeah.
Aakrsh: It's when the
Aakrsh: Slope of the derivative is zero. Yeah, correct.
Brian Nguyen: Yep. Okay. So,
Brian Nguyen: So we can go back to
Brian Nguyen: What is the derivative
Brian Nguyen: We went away, we can think about it is essentially finding a slope.
Aakrsh: So an example.
Brian Nguyen: Is like a line.
Brian Nguyen: Right, so each point here.
Brian Nguyen: We case we want to find an instantaneous
Aakrsh: Spoke
Brian Nguyen: I spoke at that point.
Brian Nguyen: All right, and delay to get that if you want to
Brian Nguyen: So the line you need two points.
Brian Nguyen: Correct. So you want to pick
Aakrsh: Two points.
Brian Nguyen: Are very, very close
Brian Nguyen: To that point of interest and kind of confused to compute the approximate line.
Aakrsh: For that
Brian Nguyen: All right. And you guys you get smaller want to get as close as you can I give you this
Brian Nguyen: Overall scope.
Brian Nguyen: At that point,
Brian Nguyen: All right, you can see that this is not to let you go down for them.
Brian Nguyen: To this one right here, there is a point
Brian Nguyen: On the curve.
Brian Nguyen: Where this
Brian Nguyen: Slope. Overall, the
Brian Nguyen: Euro.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
Brian Nguyen: So that's kind of kind of work from
Brian Nguyen: From from algebra.
Brian Nguyen: All right. Okay. So we'll have a way to
Aakrsh: Kind of verify that
All right.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so I say that's the introduction. I want to share to you guys about
Brian Nguyen: Quantum Chemistry. So it's running to give you guys an idea of kind of what's happening. And then now we're going to explore pretty much
Brian Nguyen: For the
Brian Nguyen: Company selected.
Brian Nguyen: And accuracy is measured
Brian Nguyen: Right. Okay. Let me save this.
Brian Nguyen: Right.
Brian Nguyen: Any last questions.
Brian Nguyen: Before I move on.
Brian Nguyen: This is a lot
Brian Nguyen: Of our new the information that you guys
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
Aakrsh: See you guys.
Brian Nguyen: Got this great we're gonna move on.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so, then we'll go to my terminal.
Brian Nguyen: Go.
Aakrsh: Go to the folder.
Yes, I do.
Theresa Carlos: I do
Brian Nguyen: You want to save your near molecule.
Brian Nguyen: Into the folder.
Brian Nguyen: That he created
Brian Nguyen: And once you
Brian Nguyen: Remember how to read
Brian Nguyen: To go to go to your
Terminal
Aakrsh: All right.
Brian Nguyen: Can you share screen. Just make sure sure your terminal.
Aakrsh: Quickly. All right.
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so the
Aakrsh: Mouth.
Jeffrey Tsai: CD.
Aakrsh: CD.
Brian Nguyen: DVD space.
Aakrsh: For slash
Now,
Aakrsh: Four slash
Aakrsh: Users. So you see that user up there is cap sensitive
Capital
Aakrsh: Going to your account really right CD.
Brian Nguyen: CD for it. Right.
All right.
Aakrsh: All right.
Brian Nguyen: Rooms going into either
Aakrsh: Documents or desktop.
Brian Nguyen: Either there was one
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so these are your files, right, so we're gonna make a folder called make directory
Aakrsh: Me here.
Brian Nguyen: MK dir
Brian Nguyen: Number that
Case.
Brian Nguyen: And then we'll just name it first.
Underscore
Aakrsh: Underscore s t
Aakrsh: And Paris.
Aakrsh: Go into that folder.
Brian Nguyen: Good, good.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so now we're gonna make another folder called make their
Brian Nguyen: Face.
Brian Nguyen: Geo
Brian Nguyen: Underscore opt C. E. O. D.
Aakrsh: Underscore, op, op t
Brian Nguyen: Underscore water.
Aakrsh: And
Brian Nguyen: All that connection is there.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so what I want you to do is to save that avocado molecule that you have
Aakrsh: Xyz
Brian Nguyen: And save it into that folder. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: All right, guys. You got that from there.
Brian Nguyen: All right, good. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So yeah, so what we can do here, guys.
Brian Nguyen: Are y'all.
Brian Nguyen: We are going to actually start running our very first
Aakrsh: Calculation.
Brian Nguyen: All right. And so the way we're going to do this is we're going to copy
Brian Nguyen: The what the what, what was the command to copy one folder from one computer to another.
Remotely
Aakrsh: Guys, remember when I took notes on this.
Aakrsh: Yeah.
Brian Nguyen: Anyone else can
Brian Nguyen: Turn into now.
Aakrsh: I will constantly review with you guys.
Brian Nguyen: Kind of what the commands.
Brian Nguyen: Kind of quiz you guys
Brian Nguyen: Are you guys kind of get from the live with it. All right.
Aakrsh: I'm CP and then like dot where you want to call it.
So CP
Aakrsh: And then the file that you're copying the
Brian Nguyen: File. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: And then, and then dot
Aakrsh: Where you're calling
Brian Nguyen: Okay. Very close.
Brian Nguyen: There's a
Nice.
Brian Nguyen: Hey, Coach. Alright, so I'll
Aakrsh: Your fingers to differences.
Brian Nguyen: Know it got is that so you see you're currently here.
Brian Nguyen: In this directory
Brian Nguyen: But does it copies of file in the
Current
Brian Nguyen: As a current
Aakrsh: Directory that you're in.
Brian Nguyen: Dot, dot will essentially copy this file here.
Aakrsh: But
Aakrsh: He did this, this
Brian Nguyen: Task, it will copy
Aakrsh: In the folder.
Brian Nguyen: For that certain documents. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so
Brian Nguyen: I think you a quick review.
CP
Brian Nguyen: CP works is you want to take the
Brian Nguyen: File. Okay. Does this computer science to it notation, I think, and then to the destination.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Aakrsh: You can see that right
Brian Nguyen: See here, I'm just doing a control see
Brian Nguyen: This video you
Aakrsh: Guys can see the command.
All right.
Aakrsh: Okay.
Aakrsh: You guys are very close
Brian Nguyen: Where we're going to do exactly so sleepy.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Does that sound familiar
Aakrsh: To
Brian Nguyen: You there.
Brian Nguyen: Is one double check.
Victoria Choi: Yes, I'm here. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Good.
Brian Nguyen: So Sep
SCP
Aakrsh: All right now.
Brian Nguyen: Let's do
Brian Nguyen: What we just said, where did you kill off.
Brian Nguyen: Water. All right, now the destination.
Brian Nguyen: The destination and that we're going to choose is
Brian Nguyen: They use our username.
Brian Nguyen: And then remember the computers that you guys chose to use model 45678 or
Brian Nguyen: The grid.
Brian Nguyen: Right, Olga cow.
Aakrsh: Right.
Brian Nguyen: So we will put in our username.
Brian Nguyen: You send an ID my user ID.
Brian Nguyen: And we put app.
Brian Nguyen: And then we'll put the IP address.
Brian Nguyen: And luckily, we can we name our IP address.
Brian Nguyen: Based on just names of our computers.
Brian Nguyen: Right, so I have my computer. It's called New York
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: All right, that's P. S.
Brian Nguyen: Is the
Brian Nguyen: Physical Sciences that you
Brian Nguyen: Were not done there.
Brian Nguyen: We need to
Aakrsh: Do a colon.
Brian Nguyen: So, this is this
Brian Nguyen: Allows you to log into this computer.
Brian Nguyen: And they learn to put period.
Brian Nguyen: All right, what
Aakrsh: Question, how do we know what our computers.
Brian Nguyen: So the way the Malian facility works is that it all. It's all latest server.
Brian Nguyen: So it doesn't matter what computer
Aakrsh: You choose.
Brian Nguyen: Who all is
OK.
Brian Nguyen: I will tell say I'll explain a little bit more
Brian Nguyen: After that, okay.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So net and period, see what happened.
Brian Nguyen: Right, you type in your password.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so what happened here.
Brian Nguyen: On Air co op water.
Brian Nguyen: No, I read the file.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so
Brian Nguyen: I know the air. This is a very common era.
Aakrsh: Era.
Brian Nguyen: People make
Brian Nguyen: I've made in the past, but you get these kids.
Brian Nguyen: So what happened is that
Brian Nguyen: Remember when I said
Aakrsh: To the
Brian Nguyen: Ls dash l
Brian Nguyen: Know when I said that this be here.
Brian Nguyen: It stands for directory, indicating that
Brian Nguyen: A folder. Right.
Brian Nguyen: To copy that file or that whole folder.
Brian Nguyen: You have to add an extra option in front of Sep is called dash or
Brian Nguyen: Does that sound familiar
Or Monday.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, sounds familiar for you guys.
Alright.
Brian Nguyen: You re type that
Brian Nguyen: Dash are
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So remember that for any soldiers, you do dash are
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: So basically I went over an example.
Brian Nguyen: Where like you might have an issue, right. Do not panic.
Brian Nguyen: You know, try to read what the air is
Brian Nguyen: Reading What happened.
Brian Nguyen: Or Google stuff by my quarters.
Aakrsh: On coffee.
Brian Nguyen: Things like that, you'll find your answer.
Brian Nguyen: Tonight, you know that the molecule has been transferred over
Brian Nguyen: I want to ask you a minute.
Brian Nguyen: Ask you guys to transfer over your file.
Does that work for you guys.
Brian Nguyen: I remember
Aakrsh: I still can't get in. So I can't get
Aakrsh: To my documents for
Theresa Carlos: Some reason when I do. Honestly, it doesn't show
Brian Nguyen: Oh boy. All right. We'll do one at a time. Chris actually day
Brian Nguyen: I was able to log into your account.
Brian Nguyen: So you guys tied to the media.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, how it is.
Brian Nguyen: I start with a story can
Brian Nguyen: You share your screen.
Brian Nguyen: Like your terminal.
Aakrsh: Yeah, sure.
Brian Nguyen: You stop sharing
Aakrsh: Yeah. Oh.
Brian Nguyen: Everyone's he gets faster now.
Brian Nguyen: The not the password, man.
Brian Nguyen: I think it's. There you go. But
Brian Nguyen: There's another one.
Brian Nguyen: Day for to
Brian Nguyen: Go get a scroll up near using the old password.
Aakrsh: The new one. Yes. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: See, I think he gets out. That's right.
Brian Nguyen: He's up there now.
Aakrsh: Yeah, you're using the old password.
Brian Nguyen: You're using the old password.
Aakrsh: Right, that's the email. I just got sent though.
Brian Nguyen: Yeah, but if matches. OK.
Brian Nguyen: So the message below. Look at the date.
Brian Nguyen: Scroll up a little bit more
Brian Nguyen: Than a message to the different dates.
Brian Nguyen: Or you want to use that date right
Brian Nguyen: So this is the
Aakrsh: 23rd 20 seconds right
Brian Nguyen: All right. Alright.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so
Brian Nguyen: It's the one
Brian Nguyen: With the MF
Brian Nguyen: In GP colon.
Brian Nguyen: That's the one that's reset.
Brian Nguyen: It takes you where you were looking at the
Older message.
Aakrsh: Oh, okay, yeah.
Brian Nguyen: Makes sense now. Yeah, they're just
Brian Nguyen: I said okay all
Brian Nguyen: Right. Okay, good.
Brian Nguyen: Like Teresa your issue you want to share your screen you see we look, we knew there.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Oh, what happened here.
Brian Nguyen: K type ls
Brian Nguyen: We
Brian Nguyen: Can ask you this file that's fine.
Aakrsh: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Can you go to CD users.
Brian Nguyen: Are your users.
Aakrsh: Good.
Brian Nguyen: Go into that folder.
Brian Nguyen: Ls
Brian Nguyen: And they're
Aakrsh: Going to that first high school outreach folder where is
That
Brian Nguyen: Older
Brian Nguyen: Faith.
Our
Brian Nguyen: Faith and an asterix
Aakrsh: Enter.
Brian Nguyen: So,
Brian Nguyen: If you guys know that's that's the way to like
Brian Nguyen: Preview within the folder.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so now you have the water
Brian Nguyen: Molecule in there. Perfect. Now that's
Brian Nguyen: SCP that file.
Sec.
Based
Brian Nguyen: On what the option that we needed
Brian Nguyen: To before we
Brian Nguyen: Are recovering the whole folder, such as the water molecule. Alright.
Aakrsh: So the STP dash are
Brian Nguyen: All right, that means
Aakrsh: Concocted folders.
Brian Nguyen: State before they we want copies
To off.
Brian Nguyen: OK.
Aakrsh: And now you want to copy this to
Brian Nguyen: A computer. Yeah. Type in your username.
Aakrsh: You see an ad
Brian Nguyen: And then the IP address, which is the
Aakrsh: Computers name.
Brian Nguyen: So there were several computers.
Aakrsh: You can use
Aakrsh: That's fine. Yeah.
Brian Nguyen: And you colon.
Brian Nguyen: Colon
Aakrsh: And then
Brian Nguyen: Yes, period.
Brian Nguyen: Engine
Brian Nguyen: Superior will essentially means
Brian Nguyen: That it will copy all the
Aakrsh: File.
Aakrsh: In the home directory
Aakrsh: Now let's a work.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so stop sharing your screen and edge.
Brian Nguyen: Address, you got you got it.
Aakrsh: All I think so.
Brian Nguyen: Good right we're saving this to the
Brian Nguyen: Workstation or not. Green Planet.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Aakrsh: Alright.
Brian Nguyen: In town and Victoria. You got it.
Aakrsh: Nice Saturday.
Brian Nguyen: Very good.
All right.
Brian Nguyen: Yeah.
Aakrsh: So am I using the password for I'm using browser for me. Is that right, yes.
Brian Nguyen: And that stands for modeling.
Brian Nguyen: Credibility now. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, let's get started.
Aakrsh: Let's get started.
Aakrsh: Alright.
Brian Nguyen: So next, go to my terminal.
Brian Nguyen: I'm excited. Ready. Alright.
Brian Nguyen: So now here's another quiz.
Brian Nguyen: How do we log into that remote computer
Was that
Aakrsh: Was SSH stuff. Why then you're like UCI net ID up, you know. And then here at the computer. Yep. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Everyone intro login
Ts.
Aakrsh: Very good.
Very good.
Aakrsh: These notes are
Brian Nguyen: Very useful because, you know, forget later on a couple days.
Brian Nguyen: Right, especially when you're learning for first time.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, that's
Brian Nguyen: All good.
Brian Nguyen: All right. I mean, is everyone in
Brian Nguyen: All right, good.
Brian Nguyen: Mia nada up or thumbs up
Brian Nguyen: Good.
You
Brian Nguyen: Ll
Brian Nguyen: LA, I have a bunch of stuff in here.
Brian Nguyen: I know. So you guys are fine.
Brian Nguyen: So on Monday.
Brian Nguyen: When you're not seeing all the
Brian Nguyen: Doctrine, the desktop and download
Brian Nguyen: That's okay.
Because
Brian Nguyen: You're not physically you didn't physically log into a computer.
Brian Nguyen: And so when you face the log into the pier it generate all of
Aakrsh: These files for you.
Brian Nguyen: But for now, it's normal.
Brian Nguyen: It's OK.
Brian Nguyen: OK, so don't worry about it too much.
Brian Nguyen: Sort of thing that is most important.
Brian Nguyen: Is make sure that you have the file.
Aakrsh: co op
Brian Nguyen: Underscore water.
Aakrsh: Alright.
Brian Nguyen: So this thing is
Aakrsh: Still not letting me
Brian Nguyen: You're not logging into Green Planet. Correct.
TV logged in. Right.
Brian Nguyen: Now I'm using the
Brian Nguyen: OK, so the computer is what
What computer is it
Aakrsh: Backward pro
Aakrsh: I mean, the computer name. Sorry.
Aakrsh: Tigers tigers.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: I'm going to stop share. I'm going to try to log into your account again.
Brian Nguyen: Okay. Is that okay, Chris.
Aakrsh: Yeah, okay.
Brian Nguyen: I
Brian Nguyen: Can make you
Brian Nguyen: Hey, come on.
Brian Nguyen: Have you been
Brian Nguyen: Doing copy paste
Aakrsh: I've been writing it out. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: I locked in.
Brian Nguyen: Sherry.
Brian Nguyen: Sherry, today,
Brian Nguyen: You know, I'm not crazy.
Okay, so
Brian Nguyen: Yeah.
Brian Nguyen: Did you use you.
Brian Nguyen: Chris
Brian Nguyen: Yeah, try again.
Aakrsh: So I try with another year like New York
Brian Nguyen: Yeah, fine.
Brian Nguyen: I shut my computer.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, yeah, he can try it.
Brian Nguyen: Can you read the same doesn't matter. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: What computer we you're trying before
Aakrsh: Tigers tigers.
Brian Nguyen: Yeah, okay.
Brian Nguyen: I can try doing model.
Brian Nguyen: For five or seven very
Brian Nguyen: Good. All right.
Brian Nguyen: Everyone caught that will move on.
Brian Nguyen: Whatever you do,
Brian Nguyen: Right now is to never run your calculation in your home directory, because that's
Aakrsh: Connected to the server. All right, to
Brian Nguyen: local server.
Brian Nguyen: To our group.
Brian Nguyen: And you run a calculation on a server, it will slow down, everyone.
Brian Nguyen: Exit. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So we're always going to be running
Aakrsh: Our calculation.
Brian Nguyen: In this folder.
Brian Nguyen: So CD for smash work.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, you ll
Aakrsh: Is it a bunch of users.
Brian Nguyen: Will see a bunch of music.
Brian Nguyen: Would be the journey.
Brian Nguyen: Makes your own directory
Brian Nguyen: Yeah.
Aakrsh: Let me
Brian Nguyen: Get let you in.
Aakrsh: Yeah, with market. So I just tried it again and tigers mean said denied, but it works for model for
Brian Nguyen: OK, so maybe I think there's
Aakrsh: Not that right name or something.
Brian Nguyen: I don't know what happened. I'll figure out
Brian Nguyen: For next year. All right. Thank you.
Brian Nguyen: That you figured it out. Good.
Aakrsh: Okay to
Brian Nguyen: Go into CD for smash.
Brian Nguyen: Work.
Brian Nguyen: For sash work is essentially the where you want to run all your calculation.
Brian Nguyen: That's basically where it's going to save all your data.
Aakrsh: On to that computer
Aakrsh: Is so
Brian Nguyen: Okay. Okay, watch easy
Aakrsh: So, okay.
Brian Nguyen: Never run your calculation your home directory or slows down three one else
Brian Nguyen: Yep. Okay.
Theresa Carlos: What did you
Theresa Carlos: Have for because I can only see
Theresa Carlos: I can't see any goes
Brian Nguyen: Up for
Work.
Aakrsh: Yeah, I can't see you.
Can
Brian Nguyen: Press Enter.
Brian Nguyen: Yes. Okay, good Ls and there might be some user there. Maybe not. Who knows.
Brian Nguyen: What we're gonna do is make your own directory India.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: And once you go into that directory
Aakrsh: Alright.
Brian Nguyen: Well for me, I have a bunch of
Aakrsh: Things in there.
Brian Nguyen: All right, what we can do is
Brian Nguyen: We're going to move and the
Brian Nguyen: Move that file called geo all ok so the way this work.
Brian Nguyen: Is that
Brian Nguyen: Another noticing them include this is
Brian Nguyen: We want to specify the pack.
Brian Nguyen: File. Alright, the password that file is located. So this is another way of thinking it right in the past, we always have been moved at file.
Brian Nguyen: In our current directory
Brian Nguyen: I just file.
Brian Nguyen: Something like that. Right.
Brian Nguyen: So why are we kind of
Brian Nguyen: Make a little bit more general.
Brian Nguyen: Or generalize this
Brian Nguyen: Is called it the path file. Okay, we want to specify the destination. Our second option.
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
So,
Brian Nguyen: What I do is I know that my file is in the home directory
Brian Nguyen: To specified home directory. Press the tilda button.
Brian Nguyen: Tilda. Tilda right somewhere on your keyboard and it will
Brian Nguyen: Be ugly.
Aakrsh: Right.
Brian Nguyen: For smash.
Brian Nguyen: If we press Tab, a couple of times.
Brian Nguyen: Have too many more stuff but
Brian Nguyen: I too many files but getting really easy search through it is the file is in there.
Brian Nguyen: Call God
Aakrsh: ever interested. Right.
Brian Nguyen: Here that
Brian Nguyen: You up
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: The tab is a way to preview what's what's in that folder.
Brian Nguyen: And then type in geo off.
Brian Nguyen: And when when you throw away trying to avoid an error.
Brian Nguyen: Is typing for specific couple first
Brian Nguyen: Few letters and in pressing Tab.
Brian Nguyen: It will
Brian Nguyen: Basically auto complete free
Brian Nguyen: Alright, have all the file with
Aakrsh: You know, similar characters.
Theresa Carlos: Okay, Jason.
Brian Nguyen: Hi, Jason.
Theresa Carlos: Hi, can I see before.
Aakrsh: Yes.
Aakrsh: So what I did was here.
Brian Nguyen: I'm going to generalize the
Brian Nguyen: Command move
Brian Nguyen: It is very similar to CP
Brian Nguyen: And all that and sec
Brian Nguyen: The generalized
Brian Nguyen: Generally what I wrote here with file.
Brian Nguyen: And that file is you works when you're in the current
Brian Nguyen: Directory. Right.
Brian Nguyen: And I'm going to specify the destination someone generalize it by saying that we're trying to look for the path.
Brian Nguyen: Of where the file is
Okay.
Yes.
Theresa Carlos: What is a CD.
Brian Nguyen: Oh, this one. Oh, there's this thing.
Aakrsh: I mentioned
Brian Nguyen: Earlier. I'm going to do a month from now on pressure
Aakrsh: Control see
Brian Nguyen: So that you guys can see that command.
Aakrsh: So to Chelsea.
Brian Nguyen: Huge push to control, see the same time me to cancel that command.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: And then
Brian Nguyen: Do envy.
Aakrsh: To the
Aakrsh: Course flash. I just
Brian Nguyen: Have a couple times.
Brian Nguyen: To kind of preview what's in the folder.
Aakrsh: All right.
Brian Nguyen: And this is I have a bunch of files.
Brian Nguyen: But that's okay and then I went to college you all
Right.
Brian Nguyen: And I just
Brian Nguyen: What I did was
Aakrsh: I typed out
Brian Nguyen: First few characters.
Brian Nguyen: Of view up
Aakrsh: And addressed stamped to autocomplete ok
Brian Nguyen: And then oppression PhD ticker.
Brian Nguyen: The movement here.
Brian Nguyen: In the folder. Alright.
Ls
Aakrsh: Is my to water.
It's going there.
Brian Nguyen: Right.
Aakrsh: That's the water file. Good.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Aakrsh: He's the thing that he wants to know keynote this
Brian Nguyen: Work file work folder is
Brian Nguyen: Unique
Aakrsh: To your computer.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so if you save
Brian Nguyen: This file in this a New York
Brian Nguyen: And if you go to model for and try to look for that file.
Aakrsh: In the work
Brian Nguyen: It's not there.
Brian Nguyen: Because it's actually physically save
Aakrsh: On that directory
Brian Nguyen: So what you need to do is you
Brian Nguyen: Need to copy that file.
Brian Nguyen: Back to
Your home directory
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Aakrsh: Because all computers will access your home directory and
Brian Nguyen: That's the only thing that's common alright so just keep that in mind. If
Brian Nguyen: You say you can't find the file, you know, what's happening is that the
Aakrsh: Best. All right.
Aakrsh: So,
Brian Nguyen: Here's the file water dot x, y, z.
Aakrsh: Right, so
Aakrsh: Let's try to
Brian Nguyen: Look into the file.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so as soon as I text editor. So do you guys remember what's at the editor that we talked about on Monday.
Aakrsh: Of VI. Yes.
Aakrsh: He is our
Brian Nguyen: VR to water.
Aakrsh: All right.
Brian Nguyen: Let's look into that file.
Brian Nguyen: See what it is before actually starting to calculation.
Brian Nguyen: Because we need to kind of understand what's
Brian Nguyen: Happening right
Brian Nguyen: To keep taking a little while for me.
Brian Nguyen: But what do you get to see a the first line.
Aakrsh: In your file should be
Brian Nguyen: The number of molecules.
Aakrsh: I mean,
Brian Nguyen: Now we're at them.
Brian Nguyen: Now we're atoms in the next few lines.
Brian Nguyen: Are the coordinates.
Brian Nguyen: For
Brian Nguyen: Each of your Adam
Aakrsh: Says x
Brian Nguyen: Y and Z.
Brian Nguyen: And these guys are all in
Brian Nguyen: A strong
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so it's good to now be familiar. What's the, what's the, what's the what's in
It.
Brian Nguyen: And it's quick.
Aakrsh: Alright.
Brian Nguyen: Colin. Just remember that.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: So here's the next thing that we're going to need to do
Aakrsh: We need to load.
Brian Nguyen: In the turbo program.
Aakrsh: Or increase Peter
Brian Nguyen: And the command for that is module.
Aakrsh: Load
Brian Nguyen: How do we know that the module is loaded
Brian Nguyen: Into typing module list.
Brian Nguyen: And usually see your terrible more
Programming.
Aakrsh: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so we're moving on to our next step.
Brian Nguyen: We're once we load our program.
Brian Nguyen: We are now going to
Convert
Aakrsh: This version of the file.
Brian Nguyen: Is XYZ
Aakrsh: Into a format that several more can read
Brian Nguyen: Okay, and the command for that is to keep
Brian Nguyen: Water
Brian Nguyen: Great, great. And symbol.
Brian Nguyen: And we're going to type this file, you can name it any file you want, but the most simplest file.
Brian Nguyen: You can name it.
Brian Nguyen: Is called cord.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: This is kind of much, much easier.
Brian Nguyen: It doesn't matter. You can name it. Anything you want. All right.
Brian Nguyen: And
Aakrsh: And that makes it like you can actually do to remove. Yes. Yeah.
Brian Nguyen: To remote then can read this file. Okay. It's a format a terminal to read and so
Brian Nguyen: To kind of understand what that formatting is
Aakrsh: This look
Brian Nguyen: Into the core file itself.
Brian Nguyen: Right, the cord.
Brian Nguyen: You see that there's slightly different
Brian Nguyen: Right format is slightly there.
Brian Nguyen: Certain right the atoms on the right side.
Brian Nguyen: The corners or x, y, z. So, the same
Brian Nguyen: But we have this dollar sign
Brian Nguyen: gorge indulge
Aakrsh: In
Brian Nguyen: Its going to indicate
Aakrsh: Have to
Brian Nguyen: Indicate reading the
Brian Nguyen: Reading the file.
Brian Nguyen: He's a nerd at the numbers is slightly different.
Aakrsh: From the XYZ coordinate
Brian Nguyen: Is because it's in a different unit.
Brian Nguyen: Right. Yes, he is called
Brian Nguyen: A comic minutes
Brian Nguyen: All right, as
Brian Nguyen: Are compensated. Okay.
Aakrsh: So, don't, don't worry about that too much.
Brian Nguyen: But the thing is that we use a comment units.
Brian Nguyen: We can run a calculation, a little bit easier.
Brian Nguyen: And because there's no there's no there's no. All right.
Brian Nguyen: We don't have to worry too much about the music.
Brian Nguyen: They are
Brian Nguyen: Doing some conversion factors. Alright.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so once you get that
Brian Nguyen: We then need to prepare outcomes.
Theresa Carlos: Mention me
Brian Nguyen: Finish up to you. Alright so next Teresa share me your screen.
Brian Nguyen: Why are we doing that.
Aakrsh: Time Victoria.
Aakrsh: A Christian got this yeah he
Brian Nguyen: Actually sent me your screen.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so what happened here is that
Brian Nguyen: You have we wanted to move
Brian Nguyen: The file. Okay, so if you look up the second line from the top.
Brian Nguyen: And the soda God
Brian Nguyen: So read the next line.
Brian Nguyen: What does that say
Brian Nguyen: That, that means that you didn't type in the file. Correct. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So you missing some
Brian Nguyen: Names. Okay, so let's try again.
Brian Nguyen: You envy.
Brian Nguyen: Tilda.
Brian Nguyen: For smash.
Brian Nguyen: You
Are people
Brian Nguyen: Oh, yeah.
Brian Nguyen: There we go. There's the file a
State.
Brian Nguyen: That's what you want to save it in
Brian Nguyen: A move it.
Aakrsh: To the file.
Brian Nguyen: And these get
Brian Nguyen: Ls
Brian Nguyen: Okay, good.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: Now you can see all that right so now we're going to
Brian Nguyen: Execute to
Aakrsh: Face.
Water
Brian Nguyen: Xyz
Brian Nguyen: And greater than
Court
Brian Nguyen: Alright everyone,
Brian Nguyen: So you see, I've been troubleshooting.
Brian Nguyen: With you guys right you see this a couple of times. Right, so
Brian Nguyen: Maybe next time, if one of you guys have a problem on our open this up to the floor and ask you guys what could be the issue. All right. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So if you just cut the cord file.
Brian Nguyen: The court.
Brian Nguyen: Will see or hear everything here.
Brian Nguyen: Soon.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so our
Aakrsh: Our corners are a little bit different. Okay. Alright, so now
Brian Nguyen: As quick is
Aakrsh: All right.
Brian Nguyen: stop sharing your screen.
Brian Nguyen: Oh, right. So,
Brian Nguyen: We have our x, y, z coordinate
Brian Nguyen: We need to now.
Brian Nguyen: What we can pass. Think of this
Brian Nguyen: As analogous to is like the the pre lab.
Aakrsh: We do run it when you do an experiment.
Brian Nguyen: You got to prepare your, your do some prep work.
Brian Nguyen: Right so equivalent to this is we need to do some
Brian Nguyen: prep work before actually line up.
Brian Nguyen: Right, and so that prep work means that we need to think about
This
Brian Nguyen: On a subatomic level. All right.
Brian Nguyen: So remember when I was
Brian Nguyen: First purchase purchase this picture. I said, How did you get the energy
Brian Nguyen: Right, if you just
Brian Nguyen: Given XYZ coordinates.
Aakrsh: All right.
Brian Nguyen: We need to
Brian Nguyen: Okay, from the electronic structure method.
Brian Nguyen: And the way we want to do it.
Brian Nguyen: Is by generating
Brian Nguyen: Molecular orbital.
Aakrsh: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Guys know what a molecular over those are
Brian Nguyen: Good ideas.
Brian Nguyen: I know how, but the courts and your
Brian Nguyen: Molecular over those are good.
Brian Nguyen: Chris Evans get get
Get
Brian Nguyen: What we need to do is we need to generate those molecular orbital. Right.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so think goes over those
Brian Nguyen: Are a description of the electron.
Brian Nguyen: Generate that we're going to use a command called define
Brian Nguyen: It's a little script. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: No GJ careful
Brian Nguyen: Take a lot of notes, there's gonna be a lot of options in here.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, I was pinpoint to do some of the
Brian Nguyen: Interest the options that were interested in
Brian Nguyen: Right. But it's like okay, Enter.
Brian Nguyen: All right, what happened here.
Brian Nguyen: Open up terminal.
Brian Nguyen: I'll be up to the library.
Aakrsh: Okay, opens up the program called terminal. Terminal
Define
Brian Nguyen: Alright so this one, do you want to do something different, just
Brian Nguyen: This press enter. Ignore that you want to put a title.
Brian Nguyen: It's okay, it's not really needed was entered. All right.
Brian Nguyen: Now you're here.
Brian Nguyen: You're in this window here.
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
Brian Nguyen: We're specifying them like john adams
Aakrsh: Cemetery.
Brian Nguyen: Where we're going to do is
Brian Nguyen: No specified items.
Aakrsh: To do that input our atoms. This command here.
Brian Nguyen: Alright we touched a
Chord
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so a chord.
Brian Nguyen: It could be any file, right. You just named it poured. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: As long as in the right format.
Brian Nguyen: Is correct. Now Adam
Curry.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, and then we want to type in one last thing is desi
Aakrsh: Okay. So notice that this will change a little bit.
Brian Nguyen: Oh,
Brian Nguyen: Wow.
OK.
Brian Nguyen: OK. OK, so there it
Brian Nguyen: Is allows you to run your calculations take advantage of this imagery of your molecule.
Brian Nguyen: So you can really you want you can turn off symmetry.
Brian Nguyen: To make a calculation goes
Faster.
Brian Nguyen: Keep that in mind.
Aakrsh: Typing I read
Victoria Choi: This one does. He was it just does he
Brian Nguyen: Yeah yeah
Aakrsh: Yeah.
Brian Nguyen: I think mine is kind of messed up, but that's
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: All right, this is all related to
Brian Nguyen: The top is called point symmetry.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Aakrsh: So, this is this is
Brian Nguyen: A don't take it as it
Brian Nguyen: Is for you guys to know that you want to know.
Brian Nguyen: More information about
Brian Nguyen: This means
Brian Nguyen: Look up point cemetery.
Aakrsh: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: It is. It's pretty easy.
Brian Nguyen: You know, we can talk, talk about it more an office. Are you interested in. Okay.
Aakrsh: All right.
Brian Nguyen: You want to type in, I read
Brian Nguyen: All right, I read is essentially
Brian Nguyen: It says right here.
Brian Nguyen: Redundant internet coordinate
Aakrsh: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: And so what that means.
Brian Nguyen: Well, because this way.
Brian Nguyen: You have lot coordinate
Aakrsh: X, y, z.
Brian Nguyen: Right. Are you guys familiar with polar
Coordinates.
Aakrsh: Yeah.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: Is and also have you heard of spiritual coordinates.
Aakrsh: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: But how will you guys 37 Talia.
Brian Nguyen: On
Brian Nguyen: Is not know. Okay, so that's okay with
Brian Nguyen: Me stop for a little bit, so they can shoot
Brian Nguyen: Show you a little bit
Aakrsh: When I
Mean
Aakrsh: He's a whiteboard.
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: He cleared this
Brian Nguyen: Drawing
Brian Nguyen: Is your plot. Okay. And if you have a line.
To
Brian Nguyen: Where you want to hear your why
Brian Nguyen: Use your
Aakrsh: Okay, so
Brian Nguyen: They can this way, you want to figure out
Brian Nguyen: What this point is
Brian Nguyen: Like January, we can say
X.
Brian Nguyen: Y.
Correct.
Aakrsh: Because that make sense yeah okay so
Brian Nguyen: Like changing different coordinate system.
Brian Nguyen: It just
Brian Nguyen: Essentially the same thing.
Brian Nguyen: But you want to find describe in a different way.
Brian Nguyen: Right through to this is what we call
Brian Nguyen: X, y, z.
Aakrsh: Or it's the same. It's called Cartesian coordinates.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: We
Brian Nguyen: Say we want to describe it.
Brian Nguyen: Using polar coordinate right
Brian Nguyen: We can still describe the same point here.
Brian Nguyen: But with a different flavor to it.
Brian Nguyen: Right. So here you can imagine.
Brian Nguyen: There's an angle here. We'll call it data or I will not qualify
Brian Nguyen: Is an angle.
Brian Nguyen: And this point here.
Brian Nguyen: Is a distance are
Aakrsh: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So we can describe this same point.
Brian Nguyen: By describing it by
Right car.
Brian Nguyen: By
Aakrsh: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Given an angel, and given the distance
Aakrsh: Are you can kind of describe the same
Aakrsh: Point. Okay. So essentially if
Brian Nguyen: You're just changing different
Aakrsh: Coordinate system.
Brian Nguyen: And oftentimes, changing different coordinate system.
Brian Nguyen: Can be a little bit easier.
Brian Nguyen: So sometimes it's easier to work in
Brian Nguyen: polar coordinate, this is what we call
Brian Nguyen: The polar coordinate
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: Does that help
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Stop share or share
Aakrsh: Or
Go back to here.
Brian Nguyen: So you want to Google, this, this is a different way.
Brian Nguyen: Of representing our coordinate it just makes that calculation.
Aakrsh: Faster.
Brian Nguyen: All right. Always use it if you can.
Brian Nguyen: Okay. Alright, so now we're done.
Brian Nguyen: With our terminate this place.
Brian Nguyen: All right, now here in the window.
Brian Nguyen: We're called the basis
Set
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: This is related to linear algebra, kind of related to Algebra two
Brian Nguyen: Does anyone know what I wonder, I kind of opened this out.
Brian Nguyen: Is anyone familiar with basis what
Aakrsh: What's the basis that
Brian Nguyen: Yesterday. All right.
Brian Nguyen: Going back to a point, I'm going to explain all this
Brian Nguyen: Very
Brian Nguyen: Very simple for you guys. Alright.
Brian Nguyen: So for basis sets.
Brian Nguyen: You guys some there with
Vectors.
Aakrsh: Right, good.
Brian Nguyen: Tanya gaudy Teresa a Christian on. Yes.
Brian Nguyen: Teresa Victoria.
Aakrsh: Yes, yes, good good today. Good.
Brian Nguyen: To see y'all know was vector is
Brian Nguyen: Finished. So this basically here, you can think of.
Brian Nguyen: It.
Aakrsh: Because
Brian Nguyen: This thing here vector
Brian Nguyen: Okay, alright. So we have a vector.
Brian Nguyen: Will call
It.
Brian Nguyen: And why
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so a basis means that
Brian Nguyen: The set of
Aakrsh: Set of
Vectors.
Brian Nguyen: Are independent
With each other.
Brian Nguyen: So an example.
Brian Nguyen: Of a basis.
Brian Nguyen: I'll just kind of give you an example to see
Brian Nguyen: One euro.
Brian Nguyen: Euro one
Aakrsh: forms a basis.
Brian Nguyen: All right. And what I mean by this.
Brian Nguyen: Is that
Brian Nguyen: You can see that
Brian Nguyen: These two phases sets are independent of each other.
Brian Nguyen: That means that they can't, you can't multiply any number
Brian Nguyen: To make this
Aakrsh: Equivalent
Aakrsh: All right.
Brian Nguyen: All right, and
Brian Nguyen: Basically, you can imagine.
Brian Nguyen: That this faces here x and y is general right can be described
Brian Nguyen: By your patients.
Brian Nguyen: By a number called
Brian Nguyen: A one.
Aakrsh: A one is a constant.
But
Brian Nguyen: This
Brian Nguyen: Right.
Aakrsh: You're
Aakrsh: Right. Does that make sense.
Brian Nguyen: So essentially you can describe ideas they describe your
Brian Nguyen: X, y,
Aakrsh: Coordinate
With this set of basis.
Brian Nguyen: Any numbers.
We call it the linear combination
All right.
Aakrsh: All right.
Aakrsh: Does that make sense to the
Spaces.
Brian Nguyen: Right, so
Brian Nguyen: So that's kind of essentially what ideas.
Brian Nguyen: Of basis. Okay, so our base is going to
Aakrsh: Be describing
Brian Nguyen: The electron for a given Adam
Aakrsh: All right. Okay.
Save this
Aakrsh: Go back.
To here.
Brian Nguyen: Now if you again. If you guys want to go.
Brian Nguyen: Into office hours. I'll explain a little bit more wider basis.
Brian Nguyen: But that's kind of the general idea.
Brian Nguyen: Here. Alright, so what we have here.
Brian Nguyen: Which we're going to list out
Brian Nguyen: All the bases head there are assigned to the atoms.
Brian Nguyen: Oxygen and hygiene.
Aakrsh: Right.
Brian Nguyen: Is called death.
Okay.
Aakrsh: We're going to use the basis hit call
Brian Nguyen: We're going to use this
Brian Nguyen: Command be
Brian Nguyen: Assigned comics basis.
Brian Nguyen: And we say all
Brian Nguyen: That would be all with a sign all the atoms that
Aakrsh: To SVP
Aakrsh: Okay.
Enter.
Brian Nguyen: That should set up.
Brian Nguyen: You do the L.
Brian Nguyen: Me that is
Aakrsh: To STP.
Brian Nguyen: Right. Moving on.
Brian Nguyen: This car.
Brian Nguyen: Here, let's
Aakrsh: Go on.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Victoria Choi: Yeah, this one.
Aakrsh: Assign the basis that
Brian Nguyen: There's a lot of babies that
Brian Nguyen: For now, we're gonna sign
Brian Nguyen: Up. Okay.
Aakrsh: All right, we're good.
Aakrsh: All right.
Brian Nguyen: Good star.
Brian Nguyen: Right now we go into this window.
Brian Nguyen: Where we. There are many ways of generating our orbitals.
Aakrsh: Let go.
Brian Nguyen: Over to
Brian Nguyen: The one we're going to use this one, he, he
Brian Nguyen: Called
Brian Nguyen: Coco guess. Okay. This will generate our orbital.
Our initial gets
Brian Nguyen: All right, and so
Aakrsh: I won't go into detail. How does it say generation orbital. Alright, so it's a
Aakrsh: PhD.
Brian Nguyen: And turn off.
Aakrsh: Some stuff.
Brian Nguyen: Read some stuff right
Aakrsh: It says
Aakrsh: You want to use extended
Brian Nguyen: A glossary. The default is
Brian Nguyen: Is why you just press
Brian Nguyen: To press enter.
Brian Nguyen: Or press why and enter
Brian Nguyen: Okay overarm electric charge of the molecule.
Brian Nguyen: Is mutual
Aakrsh: So 03
Again,
Brian Nguyen: It's now generating the occupation of the electrons.
Brian Nguyen: IV count up the total electrons.
In your
Aakrsh: Senior molecule that's just some of
Brian Nguyen: The same number or and then it's just
Brian Nguyen: Awkward mind orbitals.
Aakrsh: He says,
Brian Nguyen: All right, now we're in this window.
Brian Nguyen: Have you guys gone through that.
Aakrsh: Yet not
Yet
Aakrsh: Can you go back
Theresa Carlos: To before
Brian Nguyen: He
Theresa Carlos: Before he
Brian Nguyen: Before he
Starts
Brian Nguyen: Yes, this armies to terminate the
Brian Nguyen: Session. Once you're done with a section, you just respond
Aakrsh: Okay, okay.
Aakrsh: Going back to you.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so now
Aakrsh: We're going to choose the method that we want to use
Brian Nguyen: Right. He
Brian Nguyen: Stands for instance the functional theory right DSP.
Aakrsh: It is not us.
Brian Nguyen: We want to use that type lens on
That turns that on
Brian Nguyen: Now,
Aakrsh: This is the method.
Brian Nguyen: There's not different methods out there.
Brian Nguyen: Where we're going to use
Aakrsh: It to change that method.
Brian Nguyen: With type funk TV.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, now if you type in just funk, you see a list of different methods available.
Aakrsh: All right.
Brian Nguyen: Yeah, I see how there's a bunch of messages there.
Brian Nguyen: So this one is the method.
Aakrsh: Alright.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, until the
Brian Nguyen: So I'm going to pose this question for everyone. All right, in the chat.
Brian Nguyen: So you guys can
Brian Nguyen: Think about it.
Brian Nguyen: So can get get get get get a feeling for this.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, which method.
Aakrsh: Or accurate and why
Brian Nguyen: Right, or
Aakrsh: No.
Brian Nguyen: Okay and and does accuracy.
Brian Nguyen: Depend on the basis
Brian Nguyen: Right. So there's a lot of different
Aakrsh: Basis that so
Brian Nguyen: There. So we'll walk to investigate that too.
Brian Nguyen: So those are two questions, and they'll try to look into. So I did just a way to get to familiarize with. All right.
Brian Nguyen: There at all different methods out there.
Brian Nguyen: So methods, a little bit more accurate.
Aakrsh: And we'll try to explore that.
Brian Nguyen: All right, two X's this window just press enter again.
Aakrsh: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So we're done here.
Brian Nguyen: We are press star.
Brian Nguyen: All right, again, when you go to our I
Parameters.
Brian Nguyen: And then we're going to turn that on.
Up.
Aakrsh: All right.
Brian Nguyen: That's it.
Brian Nguyen: So, generally they give you a really
Brian Nguyen: general idea what our ideas.
Brian Nguyen: Are I help
Brian Nguyen: You to speed up the calculation to
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: For people who are familiar with calculus.
Brian Nguyen: Essentially when you're competing you're integrals.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: Think of this as a giant meters.
Brian Nguyen: You guys know what makes
Brian Nguyen: Right, okay.
Brian Nguyen: These guys has a very
Brian Nguyen: There's a giant matrix and
Brian Nguyen: It's a buy
Brian Nguyen: 1 million by 1 million
Aakrsh: All right, that's a lot of calculations and each
Brian Nguyen: Element is integral to compete and
Aakrsh: Because our I essentially what it does is that ignores a certain number of integral
Brian Nguyen: Okay, because sometimes those integrations.
Aakrsh: Are very small
Brian Nguyen: You guys contribute to the energy
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: That's the general idea to say to the general idea is that all right.
Brian Nguyen: beats up your calculations.
Brian Nguyen: Are enormous certain numbers of
Aakrsh: Intervals. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: We're done here.
Brian Nguyen: I think that's it. So that's all. Yeah.
Brian Nguyen: That's all she wrote. Right.
Brian Nguyen: So we pitched our
Brian Nguyen: To Ella.
Brian Nguyen: What's in it.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so we generate some new file.
Aakrsh: We have
Brian Nguyen: A basis, which was
Brian Nguyen: What we were talking about earlier.
Brian Nguyen: The basis of we have ox basis. This is where we turn our eyes. Right. And we have the control file.
Brian Nguyen: This is all the parameters.
Brian Nguyen: You have in there.
Brian Nguyen: You kind of modify it. Alright.
Brian Nguyen: So we can end this is the emos can look over those that
Aakrsh: Were generated. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So let's let's look into each of these files are you guys are summarized what was in it.
Brian Nguyen: So there's a control file.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Aakrsh: Do you notice that
Brian Nguyen: You know, here's a title tonight is the cemetery.
Brian Nguyen: Is the basis that you use.
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: You just tell me the parameters of India.
Aakrsh: So you guys are with
All right.
Brian Nguyen: This is some of the memory. There's a bunch of parameters, right, Harry, the bunch. Right. But the interesting thing that you make sure is that you have the correct functional
Aakrsh: Right movies or we call it the method and then
Brian Nguyen: We know that we turn our eyes.
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: And that's it.
Aakrsh: So,
Brian Nguyen: This calculation would run a quick. Alright, though he lives in do is important.
Aakrsh: To run a geometry optimization
Brian Nguyen: It command is called
Brian Nguyen: Job that
Aakrsh: Way. Mr. Right.
Aakrsh: Yes.
Aakrsh: Okay, so for basis and octopuses octopuses is the ones like RI, so it has like some less so it generally has all the information of basis like basically I'm asking for basis is just all the information of ox basis, plus some
Brian Nguyen: OK, so the basis
Brian Nguyen: described her
Aakrsh: As a
Brian Nguyen: Whole space.
Brian Nguyen: Okay. And I think the oxidative stress smaller space within that basis. Yes.
Brian Nguyen: So I
Brian Nguyen: Kind of speaker that way.
Brian Nguyen: Right. And I'm going to use some film come late 60s.
Brian Nguyen: Example, I think the notation that we do is eliminate some of the English girls.
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: I'm probably explaining some more tomorrow to
Brian Nguyen: Yourself by so
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: Yeah, so this is
Brian Nguyen: This is why, this is why I kind of want a separate office hours with the lecture today.
Brian Nguyen: So I came up. Sure, I can give you the bare bones in the
Brian Nguyen: Office hours I can give you a little bit more
Brian Nguyen: Information. Alright.
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so now we're going to do.
Brian Nguyen: Job at
Brian Nguyen: National right
Alright.
Brian Nguyen: So that's the command.
Brian Nguyen: Job x is a command that runs the geology.
Aakrsh: Opposition.
Brian Nguyen: And it's based national right
Brian Nguyen: One last thing we like to do
Is you have caught know help
Brian Nguyen: Right. No, he
Brian Nguyen: See no hang up.
Brian Nguyen: That means that you can wear your calculation in the background.
Brian Nguyen: And if you your calculation takes a long time.
Brian Nguyen: You can just draw out from the computer.
Aakrsh: They come back to check on it.
Brian Nguyen: Later on,
Brian Nguyen: And this ensures that the calculations continue to running when you log out.
Aakrsh: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: And to indicate that is the lead in the background.
Brian Nguyen: Question percent this is located under your shift.
Number seven.
Brian Nguyen: The press enter.
Brian Nguyen: Now it's pretty quick.
Brian Nguyen: I just the fun part is the easy part.
Right.
Aakrsh: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So we can do Li
Brian Nguyen: Jerry some more files, it shows it is geo optimum rich
All right.
Brian Nguyen: And if you want to see the each cycle.
Brian Nguyen: Will do graph X gradient
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so you should see
Brian Nguyen: That who's the energy generated
Brian Nguyen: The initial step.
Brian Nguyen: And here's the energy
Aakrsh: Again,
Brian Nguyen: As improved right
Brian Nguyen: The idea is that after
Brian Nguyen: Each cycle iteration.
Alright.
Aakrsh: So the idea is the way it works.
Brian Nguyen: I'm just going to explain it that you have your orbital.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, and just trying to
Brian Nguyen: Find the best orbital.
Brian Nguyen: To describe your molecule purge right
Brian Nguyen: Once you get to that it didn't.
It didn't
Aakrsh: compute the derivative or here.
Brian Nguyen: Is the route that we're talking about.
Brian Nguyen: And the slope. Right.
Brian Nguyen: Yeah. And the idea is that these are
Brian Nguyen: run these calculations that can
Brian Nguyen: Be exactly zero. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Because we're approximating
Aakrsh: All these things.
Brian Nguyen: But what we want to do is you want to get as
Close.
Aakrsh: To accurate.
Brian Nguyen: Result in a way to show that
Brian Nguyen: Is that
Brian Nguyen: If our cycle.
Brian Nguyen: Here and you hear
Brian Nguyen: The difference between these two.
Brian Nguyen: Numbers.
Aakrsh: Are within a certain tolerance.
Aakrsh: And we said,
Brian Nguyen: We will consider that
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: In our cases it was within like 10 to the minus
Brian Nguyen: Three attention to my
Brian Nguyen: OK.
Aakrsh: So the third decimal, actually. Sorry.
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
Brian Nguyen: So that's one criteria and other criteria is
This energy here.
Brian Nguyen: Doesn't change within 10 to the minus six.
Brian Nguyen: OK, so the six decimal place right here.
Aakrsh: Alright.
Aakrsh: So that's how
Brian Nguyen: Some of the criteria as we define party on pre authorization
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: And here's a question. This is
Brian Nguyen: It just gives you a converged result. So we want to verify
Brian Nguyen: That the molecule is truly at a ground.
Brian Nguyen: State right and we run a real force.
Aakrsh: A, of course.
Aakrsh: And what that
Brian Nguyen: does is that it tied to
Brian Nguyen: It looks at the
Brian Nguyen: The vibrational so molecules to vibrate.
Brian Nguyen: Is what we call it vibrate.
Aakrsh: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: And this allows us can
Explain.
Brian Nguyen: Determine whether or not your molecules that are true ground state.
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So we'll just type that in.
Brian Nguyen: We did the same thing no help to
Brian Nguyen: Just in case. But this is pretty quick calculation is that
Right.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so a of course
Brian Nguyen: This remember that this thing. I'll put the file.
Aakrsh: Right.
Brian Nguyen: Now we're going to look at a file.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, and now we see the output.
Brian Nguyen: For a
Brian Nguyen: Girl in
Brian Nguyen: The bunch of thing.
Brian Nguyen: It reads into the model.
Brian Nguyen: The atoms.
Brian Nguyen: Reason the basis that
Aakrsh: Region that
Aakrsh: He's in the UK very business it
Aakrsh: All right.
Brian Nguyen: Do some more calculations, blah.
Aakrsh: And here's what we're interested in.
Aakrsh: The
Aakrsh: vibrational frequency
Brian Nguyen: And normal modes of your molecule.
Alright.
Aakrsh: So what you want to
Brian Nguyen: Find here is that the first
Brian Nguyen: user base, no state.
Brian Nguyen: Is zero. There's no imaginary
Aakrsh: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: How to know that there's imaginary if there is an eye.
Aakrsh: Next to this.
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: And I will indicate that your molecule is not
Brian Nguyen: At a ground state, and you need to rerun topics.
Again,
Brian Nguyen: This is one of one of the ways to do a sanity check.
Brian Nguyen: Of your, your calculation. OK.
Aakrsh: Questions. They're good.
Brian Nguyen: Night.
Brian Nguyen: You know, I can try to explain this a little bit more
Brian Nguyen: Tomorrow and say, and also there is a lot of things.
Brian Nguyen: To say slinky because it's
Aakrsh: Bare bones. So you guys
Okay, what things does
Brian Nguyen: All right, good. All right, so that's good.
Brian Nguyen: So there's your very first terrible calculation.
Brian Nguyen: Very simple, very easy right
Brian Nguyen: So we're gonna talk a little bit
Alright, so let's make a directory
Brian Nguyen: And call it PB alright so generally you want to make folders that corresponds to the method that you
Use
Aakrsh: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: And so, and then we're going to do one last thing.
We're going to TV.
Brian Nguyen: And we're going to make
Aakrsh: The directory depth to at the p
Brian Nguyen: Alright, that's it.
Brian Nguyen: But this is kind of the way you want to kind of
Brian Nguyen: Organize your things
Aakrsh: Right. So now we're going to do and the
Aakrsh: Route move everything in here.
Brian Nguyen: All right, we'll press star.
Brian Nguyen: And just type in
Aakrsh: Just to execute
Brian Nguyen: All right, it's okay to smear is trying to tell a story.
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
Brian Nguyen: See, see that
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So for practice. I want you guys
Aakrsh: To make
Make directory
Aakrsh: Yes to
PvP
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: And what we're gonna do.
Brian Nguyen: We're going to go to win a copy
Brian Nguyen: The core file.
Brian Nguyen: In depth to FTP
Brian Nguyen: And two deputies easy. Alright, so remember the question I asked in
Brian Nguyen: Chat.
Brian Nguyen: Does the basis that
Brian Nguyen: Change the
Brian Nguyen: overall accuracy of
Aakrsh: It. Okay, so
Brian Nguyen: I want you guys to practice.
Brian Nguyen: Regenerate.
Brian Nguyen: This file.
Brian Nguyen: Rerun the calculation with a different basis set
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: That's first step.
Brian Nguyen: The second step.
Aakrsh: Is
Aakrsh: I want you guys to run
Brian Nguyen: TPS as he
Brian Nguyen: A different method.
Brian Nguyen: I want to run it with two different bases set to
SCP
Brian Nguyen: Do the same thing, but this time around.
Brian Nguyen: Run different lessons.
Brian Nguyen: On it.
Brian Nguyen: And last one.
Brian Nguyen: For kicks will call this
Brian Nguyen: That I think I'll leave this right here. All right. Can you guys do this for me.
Brian Nguyen: For next
Brian Nguyen: 20 minutes
Alright.
Brian Nguyen: So we'll call this a mini lab session.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: Before we get started, they have a
Question.
Aakrsh: More still running with water right
Brian Nguyen: Yes, same one.
Brian Nguyen: We're trying to keep
Aakrsh: Everything consistent right
Brian Nguyen: You know you want to.
Brian Nguyen: Change a
Brian Nguyen: Few variables as possible.
Aakrsh: Right when you're running an experiment. Right.
Brian Nguyen: This is one way
Brian Nguyen: Right, we're all going to run on water.
Aakrsh: And we're all trying to try to see what
Brian Nguyen: What what what we get the energy to total energy quit. Okay. And then we're going to compare this to a very accurate that
Brian Nguyen: See which methods with
Brian Nguyen: Which that is accurate. Okay.
Can you see
Brian Nguyen: Yes.
Brian Nguyen: So remember that in the chat. I wrote in the chat.
Brian Nguyen: I said,
Brian Nguyen: Which methods.
Brian Nguyen: To the most accurate.
Brian Nguyen: And how how
Brian Nguyen: Does the basic that affects
Aakrsh: The activities.
Brian Nguyen: Okay. And so when you run the car shop ization we're going to try to look at the total energy
Brian Nguyen: We're going to look at the bond distances.
Brian Nguyen: Right. And it was a look at the bond angle.
Aakrsh: All right, and then we're going to compare this to
Brian Nguyen: A reference some some very hot.
Brian Nguyen: Very
Brian Nguyen: accurate calculations or experiments.
Brian Nguyen: That we have. All right.
Brian Nguyen: So generally, we want to be able to
Brian Nguyen: match our calculation with our experiments. Okay. All right, so
Brian Nguyen: What I want you guys to do is has kept PV already
Brian Nguyen: I'm worried that it goes to the same
Brian Nguyen: Step this
Aakrsh: Step TTP
Aakrsh: With their basis.
Brian Nguyen: And then also wanted to guys use a different method.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, and the same basis it
Alright.
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
Aakrsh: This is kind of put you guys into
Brian Nguyen: Practice. So this guy is going to give you a feel for what's happening.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Aakrsh: Brian
Aakrsh: Hundreds.
Aakrsh: Of
Jeffrey Tsai: What we went over just now.
Jeffrey Tsai: With just like bare bones directions and
Jeffrey Tsai: The more detailed procedure.
Jeffrey Tsai: So sure, I'm done writing up
Aakrsh: To write up
Aakrsh: Yeah.
Jeffrey Tsai: There's so
But yet you say
Jeffrey Tsai: Also, it's a pain to the gods, because there's a bunch of dependencies.
Brian Nguyen: Yeah, yeah. I think if he did you
Brian Nguyen: Do app get don't have a gadget should be fine.
Jeffrey Tsai: I tried that. And yeah, didn't work.
Brian Nguyen: Out.
Jeffrey Tsai: And worked out because of the dependency is like see Megan.
Jeffrey Tsai: Cute.
Jeffrey Tsai: Yeah.
Brian Nguyen: The way.
Jeffrey Tsai: To
Brian Nguyen: Bring a third of the computer.
Jeffrey Tsai: I mean you didn't really have much in terms of like programs everything
Jeffrey Tsai: And yeah, I'll
Jeffrey Tsai: Figure it out over time.
Brian Nguyen: Yeah, okay. No way.
Oh,
Brian Nguyen: Feel free to ask questions.
Brian Nguyen: We'll reconvene again around 11
Brian Nguyen: So pretty fast. So hopefully
thanh: I see you. Can I see what you did earlier. One more time.
Brian Nguyen: Like what
thanh: Can we scroll up little
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
thanh: Okay, thank you.
Victoria Choi: Thing again.
Brian Nguyen: Yes, you're gonna have to redo it for each one to get a feel for it. So, you know, there's define this is kind of setting up your calculation. Right.
Brian Nguyen: Is remember what does define what's the goal define define
Brian Nguyen: Your calculation by generating your molecular orbital. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, I'll be back.
Brian Nguyen: Jeffrey, can you take over and we'll get some water.
Yeah.
Jeffrey Tsai: Actually, let me see if I
Jeffrey Tsai: Can get onto the zoom one here now, so I can share screen if needed.
Brian Nguyen: Everyone else
Theresa Carlos: molecular geometry.
Brian Nguyen: I want you guys to compute the molecular ground state geometry.
Brian Nguyen: The different methods.
Brian Nguyen: And different basis.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So that's, I can't give you guys a feel.
Brian Nguyen: The ideas that
Brian Nguyen: You know, just when I get to see what happened. Okay, thanks for it, but it's kind of small, simple case.
Brian Nguyen: And then we'll move on to something a little bit more chemistry related
Brian Nguyen: Calculation.
Brian Nguyen: stuck somewhere.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, well I'll check in. Again, I love it. Alright, so hopefully, fingers crossed that you guys finish all your calculations by done. That's my optimistic.
Victoria Choi: So, for
Victoria Choi: The calculations instead of writing it all.
Victoria Choi: We replace it with something else.
Brian Nguyen: Yes, don't be all the PvP
Victoria Choi: All caps.
Brian Nguyen: Leave
Brian Nguyen: depth to it, lowercase.
Brian Nguyen: GDP all cap. Okay.
Thank you.
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
Brian Nguyen: See
Brian Nguyen: I see some confused look
Brian Nguyen: Chris
Brian Nguyen: Oh, you're, you're on mute right now.
Aakrsh: I terminal crash.
Brian Nguyen: Crash. That's okay. It happens.
Brian Nguyen: Happened.
Brian Nguyen: Oh man, so many, so many bogus happening with
Brian Nguyen: Your computer
Aakrsh: No idea.
Aakrsh: Okay.
Why are you drinking
Brian Nguyen: Coffee.
Aakrsh: Yeah, she's
Brian Nguyen: Ain't
Brian Nguyen: Email all you guys
Brian Nguyen: Something that you in the morning.
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
Brian Nguyen: Well, we'll take a look at that will be our next step after this project, right.
Aakrsh: Alright so molecular structures. Yes, they're all
Brian Nguyen: Like three structures, I get I've already optimized them all. Okay, I'll, I'll explain this later on. Okay. I have a few things that
Aakrsh: Like you guys to do with that.
Brian Nguyen: First
Aakrsh: Purchase get started.
Aakrsh: All right.
How far you guys gotten
Brian Nguyen: A call and get a feel for this.
Brian Nguyen: Have you guys GOTTEN THE PB with
Brian Nguyen: Deputies easy
Calculation.
Victoria Choi: I did it. I think I did it.
Brian Nguyen: Oh, alright. And you verify that is a
grantee
Aakrsh: Going to control to do that.
For
Brian Nguyen: Command.
Brian Nguyen: There's a command called so forth.
Brian Nguyen: So you get out put out
Brian Nguyen: A force for Air Force to a forced out
Brian Nguyen: Going to verify that your structure that I found
Brian Nguyen: Very good, you got TV yes to PvP done for you guys.
thanh: I'm still working on
That okay
Brian Nguyen: We are there any don't work for in the same boat.
Theresa Carlos: Yeah, I'm still working on it to
Brian Nguyen: God
Theresa Carlos: I'm still figuring out how to get
Theresa Carlos: I can
Theresa Carlos: I can open
Theresa Carlos: So figuring out how to get to
Theresa Carlos: This list.
Theresa Carlos: Basis.
Brian Nguyen: share your screen. It's like, look at this.
Theresa Carlos: Yeah.
Theresa Carlos: Okay.
Don't worry about it. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: You want to make as many mistakes.
Brian Nguyen: You can just don't make the mistakes on exam, right.
Brian Nguyen: All right. Oh.
Brian Nguyen: That's okay. All right. All right, so this window scroll up a little bit.
Brian Nguyen: There you go. Oh.
Brian Nguyen: Oh, somehow you have nine had
Brian Nguyen: I think we all have three items.
Theresa Carlos: I have three first and I i like i did it a couple times.
Brian Nguyen: That's what happened. So do Control C.
Brian Nguyen: Or restart it.
Theresa Carlos: The Congo, D.
Brian Nguyen: One define
Brian Nguyen: Oh wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Brian Nguyen: Until de de
Brian Nguyen: Do LS
Brian Nguyen: So,
Brian Nguyen: Remember, we want to run our files. We want to be organized
Brian Nguyen: And the whole organization. Right.
Brian Nguyen: So we wanted. Have you move your optimize structured in the TV file folder.
Brian Nguyen: Is go into it CDP
Brian Nguyen: Star a star and see what's in it.
Yeah.
Brian Nguyen: That means that he didn't care he needs it, you're calculating coverage.
Brian Nguyen: 90 obviously you haven't moved to move the files into that folder. Okay, let's go back one folder.
Brian Nguyen: CD space double period.
Ls
Brian Nguyen: Oh, okay. I'm teacher results converge.
Brian Nguyen: Before this, or no.
Theresa Carlos: I'm not sure I'm
Brian Nguyen: Okay, we can use. We're going to use this as an example for, you know, for reference in the future. Now, so let's make a folder called air.
Brian Nguyen: Nope. Touch makes a file, we want to make a folder directory so MK dir
Brian Nguyen: Air
Brian Nguyen: And the space star.
Brian Nguyen: Move everything to the airport space.
Brian Nguyen: No.
Brian Nguyen: So it's the last part, you need to specify the destination star space.
Brian Nguyen: Nope, nope, good here. Yep. Take the air. Yes. There you go.
Brian Nguyen: Good.
Brian Nguyen: Excellent LS
Brian Nguyen: All right, here's what I want you to do.
Brian Nguyen: Go into the air folder.
Brian Nguyen: Move that BB AMP T says file that one folder to me.
Brian Nguyen: TV.
Brian Nguyen: NV dB.
Brian Nguyen: T. H.
Brian Nguyen: T. P. S. Sh.
Brian Nguyen: Space.
Brian Nguyen: You can double period.
Brian Nguyen: Happens. Okay. La.
Brian Nguyen: La, la, okay. You see that right so what we're gonna do is a CP
Brian Nguyen: Cord faith.
Brian Nguyen: Based
Brian Nguyen: Period.
For
Brian Nguyen: The first couple of times.
Brian Nguyen: You see all the files nurses PB
Brian Nguyen: Which is copying TV. TV. TV.
Brian Nguyen: Oh, oh no, you went too fast. That's okay. Let's go back one folder.
Brian Nguyen: TV.
Brian Nguyen: And TV.
Brian Nguyen: To death to Sep
Brian Nguyen: Sep
Brian Nguyen: Nope, nope, nope, no star.
Brian Nguyen: That to that SVP
Brian Nguyen: into that folder contest to bash Sep
Brian Nguyen: Sep
Brian Nguyen: tember sensitive, you get
Brian Nguyen: Into the LS
Brian Nguyen: losing, losing today and it's going to death to Sep
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Alright guys, we're gonna go over define again. So you guys want to follow along with the share screen. Alright, so now you see the court right let's double check the court file C chord.
Brian Nguyen: Okay perfect days three Adam. Okay, perfect. Now let's get out
Brian Nguyen: What you do
Brian Nguyen: Yeah, I don't think he
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so
I
Brian Nguyen: Think this one, it might be confusing. So to do colon. Q.
Brian Nguyen: Is way to quit out those x five. Okay. Enter an F, G, again, and she wants to try, you put enough for now.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, colon. Q.
Brian Nguyen: Yeah. So now, don't use Control V
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: If you type in Control Z. That puts to calculate that puts everything in the background. All right. It's just us colon to you okay to quit. I didn't push for Ghana, f, g again.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, and then quit colon to
Brian Nguyen: See a few files that was in the background. OK, so now. Alright, so now let's go over define
Brian Nguyen: You guys can all follow. Right. So there's that inter
Brian Nguyen: Inter just, it doesn't matter. You put a title. Okay, now in its put in our molecule.
Brian Nguyen: A cord.
Brian Nguyen: Right. Remember guys,
Brian Nguyen: Take note right write down these notes to do need to practice district desi d s want
Brian Nguyen: You to all the options insider
Brian Nguyen: D.
Brian Nguyen: Know. Enter again.
Brian Nguyen: He is one
Brian Nguyen: And then I read
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Okay then BL
Brian Nguyen: Know,
Brian Nguyen: That's not what you want to enter
Brian Nguyen: So we do be space all
Brian Nguyen: face death to Sep
Brian Nguyen: This one's all caps STP is OK.
Brian Nguyen: To find
Brian Nguyen: And then enter star.
Brian Nguyen: To generate your own
Brian Nguyen: Accord both the yes
Brian Nguyen: What's overcharge
Brian Nguyen: Is a watermelon moment. Alright, so P 00
Brian Nguyen: Okay, this occupation enters
Brian Nguyen: DSP for
Brian Nguyen: DSP.
Brian Nguyen: Change a method called funk SU n g
Brian Nguyen: PV know that gives you the list of functional. That's okay.
Brian Nguyen: Press Enter again.
Brian Nguyen: I've been funk.
Brian Nguyen: peavy
Brian Nguyen: Finish this window star.
Brian Nguyen: And then
Brian Nguyen: Right, you see all the files generated memos generated looks good and tool five day basis it you know are now dude, no hub and no H
Brian Nguyen: Up.
Brian Nguyen: Space.
Brian Nguyen: Called x to be the x space dash RI
Brian Nguyen: And present
Brian Nguyen: Seven or something that that's already called N percent. Yep, yep, yep. Enter.
Brian Nguyen: Enter again.
Brian Nguyen: It ran the calculation to ls
Brian Nguyen: See, now I can bridge right so now this calculation is done. Now, one last thing you want to do is a force.
Brian Nguyen: To double check that it is a truly a ground ground state or minimum local minima AO AO for for fo, r e and then greater than symbol.
Brian Nguyen: Air Force out there, generally you want the output to a file. Okay, this is one way of doing it.
Brian Nguyen: To force them out.
Theresa Carlos: You
Brian Nguyen: Know, just name the file as
Brian Nguyen: They need to kill your
Brian Nguyen: Air Force to type out. It'll force.
Brian Nguyen: Good doc out
Brian Nguyen: Out, out right now. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: That is, it is a way to say that it is Tantra output, you know, just remember that it is it is whatever way you want to name it fits and make sure that you you're aware, okay. Yeah.
Brian Nguyen: All right, there we go. So your first calculations done
Brian Nguyen: If you take out the Air Force file. And if you do graph X gradient to grow.
Brian Nguyen: X gradient
And
Brian Nguyen: That gives you the energy. Okay. And that gives you the rudest alright respect to your energy, your energy respect to a jury and respect your decision you electronically, or your Adam's
Brian Nguyen: Right. And the way it shows that converges is by comparing the last two cycles it there within a certain tolerance.
Brian Nguyen: I mean is converging. Right. So, for example, the energy doesn't change up to the sixth decimal.
Brian Nguyen: And if the if the derivative doesn't change up to the third or fourth decimal place. You're good, okay.
Brian Nguyen: All right. And if you look at the AFL CIO forum.
Theresa Carlos: Yeah.
Brian Nguyen: You know the tech Saturday.
Brian Nguyen: No, no.
Brian Nguyen: Scroll down
Brian Nguyen: The output.
Brian Nguyen: You can also press Control F to go forward.
Brian Nguyen: And control vehicle backwards.
Brian Nguyen: Control forward on foreign
Brian Nguyen: Relations, we
Brian Nguyen: Go.
Brian Nguyen: Back to that.
Brian Nguyen: So if you look at the frequency
Brian Nguyen: First to free your first few if you can see or non negative or zero or positive, you're fine. That means that your structure that account state. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: At a minimum, alright so that's it and you can you repeat that for a different method in this basis.
Brian Nguyen: Does that help you
Brian Nguyen: Thank you. Okay, stop sharing
Brian Nguyen: Halfway you guys
Brian Nguyen: I can't hear you.
Aakrsh: Can you hear me.
Brian Nguyen: Yes, I can hear you now.
Aakrsh: I think I got it. Remind every time I try to, like, I hit Enter, at the end. And just like brushes.
Brian Nguyen: Right. So this is where you can
Brian Nguyen: See what's the air output.
Aakrsh: can explore it says system restart required
Aakrsh: I think I got it though.
Brian Nguyen: Okay. All right.
Brian Nguyen: Well, we can take a look at it you know later, too.
Brian Nguyen: But yeah, so you'd run GMP opposition. How to verify this trance state.
Aakrsh: Local minimum
Brian Nguyen: 10
Brian Nguyen: How far you young
thanh: I think I gotta
Brian Nguyen: Eat all of it. Wow. Okay, so you got the TV.
Aakrsh: With
Def TTP
thanh: Ah,
Aakrsh: I'm
thanh: Still kind of working on it, but I think I understand how to do it.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so I went over.
With three, sir.
Brian Nguyen: All right. You can do this on your
Aakrsh: Own time to
And then
Brian Nguyen: We can continue on with that on Friday. Okay, so she could run the calculation.
Aakrsh: So,
Brian Nguyen: This is a mini assignment for you guys.
Brian Nguyen: So get those
Brian Nguyen: calculations done
Brian Nguyen: For Friday.
Brian Nguyen: And I'll show you something else for that.
Brian Nguyen: All right, and then Victoria. How's it going,
Victoria Choi: Um, I finished all of them, but I just now realized that
Victoria Choi: I didn't do
Aakrsh: The TP SSH.
Victoria Choi: Right, because I
Victoria Choi: Thought
Brian Nguyen: He instead of
Brian Nguyen: Me to redo that that happened to. So there's two issues.
Brian Nguyen: To way.
Brian Nguyen: Of conduct.
Brian Nguyen: We can fix it and it tried to fix it so that in the future, people can see how to fix it.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so
Brian Nguyen: You sharing your screen.
Aakrsh: And then everyone to just kind of follow around
Brian Nguyen: You kind of
Brian Nguyen: Get this session.
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Aakrsh: All right, can you make that a
Brian Nguyen: Terminal a little bit bigger.
I
Aakrsh: Think you can
Brian Nguyen: Do, Control Shift plus
Aakrsh: Does that work.
Victoria Choi: Now,
I can make the text bigger
Brian Nguyen: Is it
Just
Victoria Choi: I can just call it this.
Brian Nguyen: Perfect, yeah it's you that. There you go. That's perfect. There we can get
Brian Nguyen: All right. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: It's going to death to SVP
Aakrsh: All right. Alright, a converged.
Brian Nguyen: Create. Now let's look at the control file. So there's two way of fixing this issue. I'll show them both ways.
Aakrsh: One is you either directly
Brian Nguyen: Edit the control file.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: There also, it's not the right basis, either.
Brian Nguyen: Okay. Is that supposed to be death to SVP alright so that's one issue.
Brian Nguyen: So,
Brian Nguyen: Okay, scroll down. So if you have an issue with
Brian Nguyen: Just the wrong message being used.
Brian Nguyen: To scroll down to the
Aakrsh: part where it says TV. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: You see that PB there. The move that cursor.
Brian Nguyen: Up to the PPT
Brian Nguyen: Right, and then you can edit that directly and do insert and then TP SSH type of TPS have a dog collar workers okay escape.
Brian Nguyen: And then save and quit.
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
Aakrsh: So we're gonna run
Brian Nguyen: Defined because
Brian Nguyen: The basis is not correct.
Aakrsh: And you get to sec okay
Brian Nguyen: OK, so now it basically what it does.
Brian Nguyen: Is can be a little bit different. So it's basically reading your control.
Brian Nguyen: File.
Brian Nguyen: The first one is the line. It says symmetry CS
Brian Nguyen: Right, so that's just reading your geometry.
Brian Nguyen: We're fine with that. Alright.
Aakrsh: The next one is
Aakrsh: The atomic structure.
Brian Nguyen: The data.
Brian Nguyen: That basis.
Brian Nguyen: You read that has been taken from blah.
Aakrsh: Blah.
Brian Nguyen: Do you want to change.
Aakrsh: These
Brian Nguyen: These data. Right. So it would be yes.
Aakrsh: Because we want to change the basis
For why
Brian Nguyen: They're in here.
Brian Nguyen: Now you can
Brian Nguyen: Type in BL you as your basis.
Brian Nguyen: Because I
Brian Nguyen: Think it's right. Right. So do you see that right when I press enter. We're going to change the basis
Brian Nguyen: On TV.
Yes.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, let's enter, enter again just reading some files.
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Here we go. All right, and then star.
Brian Nguyen: Wars next window.
Brian Nguyen: Essentially using different career basis. We want to delete this.
Month.
So,
Aakrsh: Yeah.
Brian Nguyen: They're not the same. Generally, we want the basis
Brian Nguyen: And the very basis to be
Aakrsh: The game.
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: Now we are regenerate our game.
Aakrsh: Good.
Brian Nguyen: You want to be here.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so now. Yeah.
Brian Nguyen: So,
Brian Nguyen: Everything, all the parameters are
Aakrsh: Going to be the same.
Aakrsh: The retiring DSP.
Brian Nguyen: It will all be there already.
Aakrsh: So you see that everything's already there. So,
Brian Nguyen: You don't need to modify it right
Brian Nguyen: You're just continue on what you
Brian Nguyen: already created right and it goes back to stop.
Aakrsh: The only thing that we're missing.
Is the RI
Brian Nguyen: RI
Brian Nguyen: Enters
Brian Nguyen: missing some basis it right
Brian Nguyen: As Mr and Mrs actors regenerated.
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: All right, so you're done.
Brian Nguyen: Right, so you can use it just
Brian Nguyen: Returned the basis that star, you're done here, started again.
Aakrsh: All right, now let's
Brian Nguyen: Go.
Aakrsh: And you can check the control file to
Brian Nguyen: See you scroll up
Brian Nguyen: Or down to get
Brian Nguyen: Their club depth to FTP
Aakrsh: There's no okay
Brian Nguyen: Let's get out and then you can just leave on job.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, we're done.
Aakrsh: So you just
Aakrsh: stop sharing now so that's
Brian Nguyen: That's how you guys can troubleshoot okay
Aakrsh: All right, so
Brian Nguyen: You want to restart from like fresh, you could do that.
Aakrsh: You can always modify
Brian Nguyen: Your file. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so now I'm going to go on to our next topic we're actually going
Brian Nguyen: To
Brian Nguyen: Before we move on.
Aakrsh: guys have questions about this.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so I want you guys to
Brian Nguyen: Get to get the calculation running and
Brian Nguyen: Finish it for Friday W sourcing little over
Brian Nguyen: Friday morning and there was my analyze
Brian Nguyen: The data. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: All right, and then
Brian Nguyen: Our next topic Luna talked about it.
Brian Nguyen: A little bit more chemistry stuff.
Brian Nguyen: All right, we may end up
Brian Nguyen: Working on it on our own.
Aakrsh: Written some calculations on our own. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So I
Brian Nguyen: Gave you guys
Brian Nguyen: These
Brian Nguyen: Guys, this
Brian Nguyen: Is called profile.
Brian Nguyen: Day to prep file here okay i sent this to you guys.
Brian Nguyen: To interns.
Brian Nguyen: Right download this
Aakrsh: All right, and then
Brian Nguyen: Open it, and unzip
Brian Nguyen: Alright so on, do it.
Aakrsh: Shared the whole desktop so
Aakrsh: You guys can see
Aakrsh: What's
Aakrsh: Right.
Brian Nguyen: Here is my
Aakrsh: Going to map.
Aakrsh: It opens up for you.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so I have this file for Internet
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So I have a bunch
Brian Nguyen: Of
Brian Nguyen: Geometry.
Aakrsh: For a bunch of molecules.
Brian Nguyen: These are things I've already pre optimized.
Brian Nguyen: And what we're interested in.
Brian Nguyen: Is I'll probably open up
Avocado.
Brian Nguyen: Alright.
Brian Nguyen: Here's the topic. This is called inner molecular
Brian Nguyen: Forces. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: You guys have shown me sample where are some examples of
Aakrsh: internal forces.
Aakrsh: In one dispersion nine dispersion, yes.
What else
Aakrsh: dipole dipole dipole
And
Aakrsh: I didn't bonds. Hydrogen bonds.
Brian Nguyen: Okay. So three things we're going to look at. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: An example, hydrogen bonding.
Brian Nguyen: Water right
Aakrsh: Interaction between this hygiene with oxygen.
Aakrsh: That
Hydrogen bonding.
Brian Nguyen: Now, this version.
Aakrsh: Interaction
Aakrsh: So these are two different molecules. Right. So this is the effing interacting with each other's and this is a water molecule.
Brian Nguyen: interact with each other right so
Brian Nguyen: Generally
Brian Nguyen: We, we say that hygiene bonding is stronger than
Aakrsh: Dispersion contractions.
Correct.
Right, yeah.
Brian Nguyen: So,
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so before we start, so
Aakrsh: What
Brian Nguyen: Can you name me all the intimate with
Aakrsh: Forces between
Brian Nguyen: To water molecule.
Brian Nguyen: tongue in cheek.
Brian Nguyen: Answer that
thanh: Sorry.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, what what internal forces.
Brian Nguyen: Are between these two.
Brian Nguyen: Water molecules.
thanh: dipole dipole
Yes.
Aakrsh: Thank you.
Brian Nguyen: Pontypool
Brian Nguyen: Dispersion Virginia and
Brian Nguyen: What else
Brian Nguyen: And you know I
Aakrsh: hadn't gone
Aakrsh: Yeah.
Brian Nguyen: At him but they had all three.
Brian Nguyen: Components. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Interesting because
Brian Nguyen: You know, interactive forces, you know, include all possible interactions. Right. And so for anything. The only interaction. You guys have here.
Aakrsh: Is
Brian Nguyen: This version.
Brian Nguyen: Right, there's no dipole dipole
Brian Nguyen: Things like that. Right.
Brian Nguyen: But the thing is,
Brian Nguyen: Now we're may be interested in
Brian Nguyen: The overall
Brian Nguyen: We can use our calculation.
Brian Nguyen: On a computer to
Brian Nguyen: binding energies of these molecules.
Brian Nguyen: And so the question we're going to try to answer or ask is,
Brian Nguyen: Think ahead and maybe question is
Brian Nguyen: How does cooperatives at
Brian Nguyen: How this cool opportunity.
Brian Nguyen: Contribute to the
Brian Nguyen: Cotton Club Katie of the naka de
Aakrsh: Interactions.
Brian Nguyen: Are the forces.
Brian Nguyen: Contribute to the
Brian Nguyen: Overall findings.
Aakrsh: The what
Brian Nguyen: The current activity.
Brian Nguyen: The like how does the. How does
You know,
Brian Nguyen: How does the size
Brian Nguyen: You know,
Brian Nguyen: Of your
Brian Nguyen: Your molecules.
Brian Nguyen: Can affect the binding energy
Brian Nguyen: So,
Aakrsh: The larger
Aakrsh: The larger the molecule, the more the more polarized bold is so it's no longer like
Brian Nguyen: Yes that's true polarized ability will be related
Brian Nguyen: London Dispersion.
Brian Nguyen: So it's sometimes the whole thing that we're kind of thinking about hydrogen bonding.
Brian Nguyen: Like it really isn't an isolated.
Brian Nguyen: Interaction. There's a bunch of other interactions.
Brian Nguyen: That contributes to the overall financial
Aakrsh: Right.
Brian Nguyen: And so if you have a very large
Brian Nguyen: You know, like
Brian Nguyen: Ideas that you have a very large
Brian Nguyen: That a molecule here.
Aakrsh: You like to say just chain of carbons.
Brian Nguyen: Up to second 10 or more right
Brian Nguyen: That
Aakrsh: That interaction.
Brian Nguyen: And be stronger.
Brian Nguyen: Than the binding energy of your water molecule.
Brian Nguyen: And then we can try to see that.
Aakrsh: In
Aakrsh: In our calculation. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So,
Brian Nguyen: I have a few other examples to interesting chemistry to
Aakrsh: So what we're going to
Brian Nguyen: Try to do is to meet open up some of the molecules. So this is another one too.
Brian Nguyen: The benzene dimer. All right.
Aakrsh: I'm gonna try to open up some articles.
Aakrsh: You guys can see it.
Brian Nguyen: On this one more. Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Right, so we have this century here.
Brian Nguyen: Right.
Brian Nguyen: Right, you have this bending dimer.
Brian Nguyen: What's very interesting here.
Brian Nguyen: Is that you have this
Brian Nguyen: Tiny energy here.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so we're gonna take a look at three different
Molecules.
Aakrsh: And open up one more.
Is this word, yes.
Brian Nguyen: But so, yes.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Aakrsh: Should we have this structure here.
Brian Nguyen: And I believe you have
Brian Nguyen: This structure here. All right.
Brian Nguyen: And if you were to stay hypothesize
Aakrsh: Which one do you think
Brian Nguyen: Which molecules you think has a stronger binding.
Brian Nguyen: Yet T shaped
Brian Nguyen: Versus this
Brian Nguyen: Stack shape.
Brian Nguyen: Well, yes.
Brian Nguyen: Are you guys ready
Brian Nguyen: Yet to see safe molecule here.
Aakrsh: And they have this stack right
Brian Nguyen: Our they are more
Brian Nguyen: On top of each other.
Aakrsh: Essentially, I'm monifieth this one because you can because like you can ladder and I'll talk to each other. It'll have stronger like attraction to each other.
Brian Nguyen: Mm hmm. Okay, that's when answer. Anyone else want to hear.
Brian Nguyen: But in the vote.
Victoria Choi: I think the sun to
Theresa Carlos: A
Tee sheet.
Aakrsh: That
Brian Nguyen: That few people voting for this.
Deck.
thanh: While ago i think that someone to
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Very
Brian Nguyen: Good. You're thinking
Brian Nguyen: Yep. Okay. So this is a reasonable get
Brian Nguyen: A very reasonable.
That
Brian Nguyen: You know that
Brian Nguyen: It overlaps a lot
Brian Nguyen: That they will bind
Brian Nguyen: It will be the ground state energy of this
Brian Nguyen: is complex and may have a stronger binding.
Aakrsh: However,
Aakrsh: This is a little bit more complicated even gotten to see
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so
Brian Nguyen: So this one is what we call staggered. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so if we add one more example where like if I had this completely
Brian Nguyen: You know the
Brian Nguyen: I had to completely over say complete on top of it to say,
Brian Nguyen: You think that will increase that will, you know, increase the bindi
Brian Nguyen: Say like completely that basically look at this is complete overlays. Right.
Brian Nguyen: Right. Okay, so now we're busy on top of each other.
Brian Nguyen: Right. So, based on what you just, you know, if he said that, you know, if we have more overlap, maybe there would be more finding right energy they embody the engine increases in that it will be the ground state of that molecule.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so we're going to try to figure out answer that question.
Brian Nguyen: But actually this I will actually give you kind of paper. They've already started trying to explain this. Right. And what they found is that this second. Here we see the complete overlay right on top of each other. It's not the ground state.
Brian Nguyen: Right. It's not the ground state, it is it has a weaker binding energy
Brian Nguyen: Then the staggered
Brian Nguyen: In a staggered a vengeance.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so say you stagger it a little bit like right here.
Brian Nguyen: This one is close. This is a much more stable molecule in this completely overlaid
Brian Nguyen: Then add a monocle crazy ass right now he's he's not a twitch.
Brian Nguyen: If you were to compare it this T shaped versus that completely overlaid overlap the vending. Which one do you think is stronger in mining, which ones more stable. Yes.
Brian Nguyen: I think we also say we said that the the argument is a is complete overlaid it will should be more stable. However, actually the key shape is more stable than the stack the end
Brian Nguyen: And they attributed to dispersion direction. Right. And so it just, it just shows you how dispersion traction are very complicated to understand
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so right now they're in contention. They're trying to date between which one is a true ground state. So right now, the debate is eternal destruction.
Brian Nguyen: Or destructive. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: And so what we're going to do is you want to try to verify
Brian Nguyen: Verify that interaction verified the result on the paper. I'll pass on that paper to you guys, take a look at to read. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: So we, we will would kind of verify the will try to verify the the
Brian Nguyen: The conclusions by actually competing divine the energy. Alright.
Brian Nguyen: To explain why. So
Brian Nguyen: That will be requiring a little bit more work. And that's what we're
Brian Nguyen: That's what our group tried to try to try to try to explore, okay, we're trying to explain why. So happening, you know, why are the numbers so and so. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: All right, so yeah, so we don't know much about non Canadian direction and, you know, even though with our intuition chemistry intuition. You can be something very wrong. Right. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: I think I have to get back to you guys.
Brian Nguyen: On the molecules of self.
Brian Nguyen: Because I think I didn't give you the correct molecules. They don't look right. Sorry about that.
Brian Nguyen: So,
Brian Nguyen: So, uh, so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
Brian Nguyen: actually tried to compete. Some of these find the energy okay so
Brian Nguyen: You can do a very simple one.
Brian Nguyen: Will do the water diamonds. Okay, I know. That's correct. All right, so, so it's dark. Right. Alright, so
Brian Nguyen: So are we going to do first is
Brian Nguyen: We are going to open our terminal.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, this, this is in the we're in. I'm in my, in my new york computer when I log out. And then when Sep those structures structures. Okay, and I'll send you updated structures. Later on, because I think some of them are incorrect. Right. So to log out his Control D.
Brian Nguyen: OK, so now you see the connection is logged out
Brian Nguyen: All right, now I'm in the first high school outreach folder where I'm going to do is going to make a directory
Brian Nguyen: Will call this nautical valence
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so we have that folder now.
Brian Nguyen: Now we're going to go back to their home directory, just type in CD and oh for Windows. Be careful. Do not type in CD.
Brian Nguyen: It goes back to your and mounted
Brian Nguyen: Home directory. OK, so I'll be careful. Actually, I went through this is the double period, whatever. And we want to go into downloads. So that's where
Brian Nguyen: I put the folder call for interns.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: We can then move this for interns.
Brian Nguyen: Back and put that
Brian Nguyen: Folder into the folder for the high school outreach. Okay, that depends on where you put that for me, I put in the document. So I'm just pointing this to the path where is alright so documents for nice grow rich and and not completely
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so, um, we'll back documents crash now.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: There.
Brian Nguyen: Stop right here briefly want to see everyone got to the stage.
Brian Nguyen: Give me a thumbs up or not. And you guys got it.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, Chris, you got to speak.
Brian Nguyen: Con not yes good three center to Korea and he has Windows. So it's a little bit tricky.
Theresa Carlos: Yeah, let's see you soon.
Brian Nguyen: Okay. Okay, so you can share me your screen with me.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, so you see that error de de de de right now if he didn't put a space. That's fine. I do LS
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so I believe you downloaded the file right for intern file.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, now let's go into download PDF download SVG where all your files are
Brian Nguyen: Ls
Brian Nguyen: Oh, right.
Brian Nguyen: For it.
Brian Nguyen: So the zip file. So what we're gonna do is we're gonna have to do a command called and yet.
Brian Nguyen: For interns.
Brian Nguyen: Underscore should be. Nope. Nope.
Brian Nguyen: Nope. So what happened is that the program is not there. So that's installed that copy
Brian Nguyen: And
Brian Nguyen: Paste in here to type, type it out. I guess you do app install on just, yeah. Sorry.
Brian Nguyen: Windows festival. Now this is the password that you use for this is going to
Brian Nguyen: Be unlocked. When you first created this account remember it.
Brian Nguyen: Oh, no.
Oh, no.
Brian Nguyen: Yeah, type in the app yet.
Brian Nguyen: Time Victoria to get it.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
I'm
Brian Nguyen: Victoria. How do you unzip your file.
Victoria Choi: Um, I just did it through terminal. But if you go to your like actual computer and then go to the files folder. I think you can unzip it from there.
Brian Nguyen: That's true.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, they're doing a terminal.
Victoria Choi: Just
Brian Nguyen: Open it from your documents in
Brian Nguyen: OK, though.
Brian Nguyen: This move on to stop sharing I'll share mine now.
Brian Nguyen: All right, so. All right, so
Brian Nguyen: That's three zero wer come back I'll get back to you on it. All right, so
Brian Nguyen: When did the same thing SAP this file.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Your computer
Brian Nguyen: Period skipped one
Brian Nguyen: So there's this structures. I'm gonna send you updated structure. I think a few of them were incorrect I'll double check. I know the water is correct. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Well then log into the computer.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, we're gonna move that file and non prevent IRC here.
Brian Nguyen: To your quarter.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Your username. Alright.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so let's go into the work order.
Brian Nguyen: So we had a non cavaillon
Brian Nguyen: Right, you got for insurance right so what we're gonna do is
Brian Nguyen: We're going to compute the binding energy for these molecules. Alright, we're use what we learned us define and then we're going to use a slightly different command. Okay. So to that everyone's going to be consistent.
Brian Nguyen: So that everyone has the same field, right. So, because I've always I supposedly I have already optimized these structures to be the true ground state. And on Friday, we can try to see if I did a good job doing that. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: They will make a directory called water.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, we
Brian Nguyen: Go, yes.
Aakrsh: What's the first thing you do. After you log into the UCI computer
Brian Nguyen: Copies of files and all of that file into the computer. Do you want to work with right here.
Brian Nguyen: Yeah.
Brian Nguyen: Yeah, okay. I use the colon period to copy into the home directory
Aakrsh: But you have to be any work to do that for me do that outside of work.
Brian Nguyen: To to run the calculation itself, you should be in work like a coffee and stuff. You can you can do this. Me show you
Brian Nguyen: You can type in this Sep dash are the smile.
Brian Nguyen: At the user
Brian Nguyen: The computer or computer that is
Brian Nguyen: Colon, now it's disco. And this means that you're just pointing it to a directory or wherever you want to do. So I needed a little bit easier. So you guys to disperse period. But as you guys learn more and try to speak up, understand this, you can actually laid out to work.
Brian Nguyen: If you know where your we want to put it. Okay. So, this essentially will copy that file to that directory. OK.
Brian Nguyen: So I'm going to Control. See you guys can
Brian Nguyen: See this
Aakrsh: file or directory them for me.
Brian Nguyen: So there are two options. One is that the computer, you have does not have this folder here so it can't copy it directly there.
Brian Nguyen: So the best safe bet is to just do a period, it will always copy home directory and you can access that all the time. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Just keep in mind to work folder corresponds to the computer you using. All right, like the like locally, your, your depth here, add on to that computer, not the server. Okay. The home directory is extra server and you can save your files. Right. And that's this is where any computer UCI
Brian Nguyen: Right, so you want to compute go into water, we're actually going to be using
Brian Nguyen: Make a directory will call a piece of H dash corporatist do underscored easy. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: D3 is the extra parameters we want to add to allow us to compute very accurate by the energy. Okay. I'll explain that later maybe maybe tomorrow if you attend office hours. But for now, this is the parameter. Do you need to compute engine luck with washes accurately. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Will do the same thing. PBS st three right in January. Want to flee the fuse.
Brian Nguyen: Death to PvP
Brian Nguyen: For designing energy recounting need
Brian Nguyen: Separate basis it. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so
Brian Nguyen: Alright so what we're gonna do.
Brian Nguyen: Is we're gonna get take her water dimer.
Up.
Alright.
Brian Nguyen: We have the water diamond.
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: All right, we'll go through the same steps.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, that's fine. We'll run through define
Brian Nguyen: Go through the same steps again a court.
Brian Nguyen: cemeteries and add this is not so that's okay maybe add I read
Brian Nguyen: Star.
Brian Nguyen: Check our basis.
Brian Nguyen: Yes, he brings up
Brian Nguyen: Whereas we don't actually do deputies to
Brian Nguyen: Check that
Brian Nguyen: We've known
Brian Nguyen: ght regenerate our molecular orbital our initial gift.
It is
Brian Nguyen: Just neutral. Yeah, looks bizarre observation and there's no warranty, not too much good.
Brian Nguyen: Go to DSP.
Brian Nguyen: Need to turn these on.
Brian Nguyen: Type in
Brian Nguyen: GPS is a
Brian Nguyen: Star.
Brian Nguyen: Turn our eyes.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, dar again.
Brian Nguyen: And Asia. This is a nice little different is an important
Brian Nguyen: DSP.
Brian Nguyen: For DSP dispersion correction.
Brian Nguyen: Okay, very important is is will be needed to get accurate finances. So the SP.
Brian Nguyen: I've been BJ to the one we want to use and use this version. Okay.
Brian Nguyen: And once it says us right here.
Brian Nguyen: So again,
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Real quick, guys.
Brian Nguyen: Good here. All right, so last thing we want to do.
Brian Nguyen: Is to r i t to our ideas.
Brian Nguyen: We're going to generate put no hub so that you can run this in the background.
Brian Nguyen: It takes some time. So, oh yeah well
Brian Nguyen: Alright so what r i t is t does the guys know is that it takes to do you have a given geometry. All right. And it computes the energy for that given geometry is not GMP optimization is essentially doing a single point energy calculation. So maybe an example maybe explain this on a whiteboard.
Let me
Brian Nguyen: Clear this
Brian Nguyen: So imagine you have a surface.
Brian Nguyen: Right. I know.
Brian Nguyen: I know I. Good. So imagine you have surface.
Okay.
Brian Nguyen: Each of these points.
Brian Nguyen: Here.
Brian Nguyen: Are some configuration of your, your molecule, right. Some orientation of the weight Adams or range. All right. And so what what geometry optimization. Does this say you start
Brian Nguyen: What geometry optimization tried to do it tries to find you a minimum. Okay. And so it would compete the energy in modified to the atoms rearranged a little bit and then you and you may end up being in this location. All right, we call a well alright
Brian Nguyen: So what we're doing here. Given a configuration. We're just competing the energy
Brian Nguyen: Alright, and we're going to use that energy to compute are buying the energy. Okay, so this is a total energy. So the formula.
Brian Nguyen: For finding energy
Brian Nguyen: Alright, this is the formula.
Brian Nguyen: For our formula.
Brian Nguyen: We are
Brian Nguyen: Going to use this equation here.
Brian Nguyen: So he is our total energy
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so where we're going to do is take root causes del there's a difference and energy will be will stand for
Brian Nguyen: Interest interaction dividing energy will equal
Brian Nguyen: The total energy
Brian Nguyen: Will call this
Brian Nguyen: Fragment is this called it monomers. A or fragment K
Brian Nguyen: Alright, so just for reference. So you guys kind of know what we're talking about. If you
Brian Nguyen: Right.
Brian Nguyen: All right, we'll call it
Brian Nguyen: A
Brian Nguyen: Call this week.
Brian Nguyen: Until
Brian Nguyen: The individual fragments
Brian Nguyen: Total energy of the complete complex, it's
Brian Nguyen: That clear how do we compete to find the energy
Brian Nguyen: So if you kind of just trying to think about it.
Brian Nguyen: We think about just completed the total area of a
Brian Nguyen: Until the end up
Brian Nguyen: Maybe subtract it from the energy of this whole complex right ideas to what stuff over. It's just finding energy
Brian Nguyen: Okay.
Brian Nguyen: All right.
Brian Nguyen: So stop sharing here.
Brian Nguyen: That's what we're going to probably doing on Friday. All right.
Brian Nguyen: So I will. I won't want to sign your homework for that one. But I can, I could be some other with that right so precursors for Friday.
Brian Nguyen: All right. Okay. I'll leave that they're not serious. Try gesture Pro. Are there questions so that we read this top 30 today we are essentially building upon what we just did.
Brian Nguyen: On Monday abashed commands. So try to keep practicing on that to get free food to it to the point where I don't need to, like, you know, remind you all that. Okay, and you can troubleshoot your own today was just kind of learn how to use several more
Brian Nguyen: Or dish on the parameters gift feel for it and that later on we work with mentors. Can I make a little bit since
Brian Nguyen: Friday, we will try to answer that chemistry question and then next week.
Brian Nguyen: When we start to finish up some things. One last thing to do. Alright.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, let's see, I have for you guys today.
Brian Nguyen: I went through pretty fast. Last section. So
Brian Nguyen: Thank you. Yeah, good.
Brian Nguyen: Good. Yeah. Thank you.
Brian Nguyen: Alright, see you guys.
Brian Nguyen: Friday.
Brian Nguyen: Or Thursday I have office hours tomorrow, so she'll be stopped by
Brian Nguyen: Teresa me stop this recording
Theresa Carlos: What
Brian Nguyen: Yeah.